we bought an Avi positive a one oh you
guys don't know I'll be positives hey
it's like an alien weiner but it has egg
inserts so you can push like a lubed egg
through so when you insert it you can
put eggs into yourself
hello welcome to another episode of the
trash taste podcast I'm your host Joey
and I'm with the boys as per usual and
uh we're kind of doing one on the road
right now we're currently on the tour
not really planned no I've winged it
yeah yeah this is a very special episode
because uh of this guy next to me
introduce yourself hey my name is
Charlie uh big moist
the man who thinks JoJo's part three and
four
already it's been two years of like
arguments in the shower with myself how
I would defend the point should I ever
get the chance so this is great for me
okay yeah because I remember if you
don't know the context I believe two
years ago you posted a video talking
about toxic Final Fantasy fans uh to do
with donkey's video I believe which was
which was valid yeah which was valid and
then on the off cuff you mentioned Jojo
and I'm like gray he has a point JoJo
fans are also toxic but then on top of
that I think you mentioned that you
prefer part one and part two to part
three and part four you're good
we had to fly like halfway across the
world just say yeah I heard you were
talking [ __ ] Charlie that was so weird
I've never had
ever had that thing of like yo what
someone said in the person and I like
just hit the Spaceball like what because
there's just no one no one's no one has
ever said that I know so do you want to
defend yourself now that you're here
yeah so I'd like to explain okay I I
hate part four the only part of part
four hates a strong word so I'm Not A
Slice of Life guy at the end did you
watch all of it yeah okay I've given I
like Parts one two and five I love part
five as well okay so part five slaps
that was this opinion predated part five
yes yes but part four it's my least
favorite genre of all Slice of Life it
was like all Slice of Life until Kira
and then it was right right so it
finishes strong and I hated everything
before it
okay I can I can kind of respect that
because I I think okay here's here's the
dichotomy right because I I agree with
you that the beginning of part four I'm
also not a slice of Life man so slow
it's very very slow but I think the best
JoJo has been so far anime wise is like
the second part of part four because
when Kira gets introduced it's so cool
yeah I agree I like Kira a lot but I
don't think he said it wasn't enough he
didn't save it because I was so [ __ ]
bored of seeing them just like walk
around the city like the manga artist
and trying [ __ ] was so important
yeah I couldn't stand it okay so
what didn't you like about part three I
was just like I'm gonna get there part
three I didn't hate nearly as much as
part four I like I actually liked all
the characters I just thought there was
a lot of times where it just became the
same formula it was very long it was
very much like I dragged so much yeah it
was very much like a monster of the week
type of thing yeah which I think a lot
of Jojo fans also weren't a huge fan of
but so you see that that was that's not
the thing that like surprised me but
like you say you prefer part one over
yeah yeah okay
that was the opinion right I totally
agree with these takes but it was just
like then then you say oh yeah part
one's better so we all watched part one
but like please sell us on part one so
part one is like your classic like
grown-up nostalgic anime right you have
your right
which is fine and cool that's what
you're used to yeah it's not trying to
do anything different but the style is
great I think JoJo Style's always been
really good yeah and I think it works
well with Jamon I love when they
introduce Dio he comes out of the gate
like this [ __ ] Menace like he's
ripping heads off and [ __ ] like he's
cool
and it's short it's not long so you get
like a very tight burst of like what
you're expecting right right so I wasn't
you know like offended I enjoyed it
don't you think that like part one was
just like a little bit too like shaky
and a lot of them there's even like the
pots from like episode like
three to five that were just like
because I feel like part one is like
Iraqi I feel didn't quite know where he
wanted to take it because the Frog had
wine yeah it's like that's all cool and
all but it's like it didn't really like
flow as a story in mind I agree and it
definitely wasn't the narrative wasn't
like the strong part of that one but I
just really enjoyed that it was pretty
unashamedly anime trophy yeah yeah like
it had pretty much every anime cliche
for its time but yeah definitely
practiced this argument
you explained yourself pretty well yeah
I just yeah even even with that in mind
I just can't the last part of part four
was so strong that I don't think I could
even I like I think part four is better
than three two one and five can we only
report two [ __ ] slaps yeah yes of
course of course of course yeah I think
part two is like I wish part two was
part one so then that would be the
introduction yeah because part one
sometimes puts people off because it's
really odd and didn't quite hit the feel
for the well you know part two he kind
of figures out what he wants to do with
Jojo and he kind of gets more campy with
it right it's more fun and he lets the
characters be weird yeah whereas part
one he's kind of like kind of still
sticking to traditional character
archetypes except for Dio is just weird
yeah and dear has always been really
weird I guess that's why he's reused him
like 19 times yeah yeah because I think
what really sold me on jojo in general
was actually when Part Two started
because I saw part one I just thought
Jonathan was like a really really boring
main character I thought is all of Jojo
gonna be like this and then you see
Joseph and you're like holy [ __ ] yeah
this is so much fun now oh my God the
Tommy Gun when he wears the Tommy Gun
yeah oh this is not gonna be a normal
show yeah when he was doing the training
and climbing up that [ __ ] pillar I
don't know everything about that so yeah
just unreasonably hyped for something
kind of like smaller and just a weird
insert of him just staring at his mom in
the back and it's like why would this be
like in like this does not fit
thematically with anything that has
happened for me it was for me it was
like right at the very very very
beginning like chapter one of them to
where like he takes the card yeah the
coke bottle like fears immediately I was
just like yeah racism is
okay but real question though now that
we've like kind of all caught up and you
know you obviously watch part five right
yep have you watched part six I've
started it and then I haven't watched
the second part of part six because the
Netflix releases dogs in town yeah I
know it's great part six I think so
everything I've seen so far is good yeah
plastic is fantastic yeah where would
you put part five in in the higher part
five would be right behind part two but
just barely better than one two three
four so it'd be two five yeah two five
eight I haven't finished six so I can't
really scale that yet but six is better
than two uh than one three and four so
far for me the only thing that really
holds back five is sure no he's kind of
boring I didn't think so I thought it
was good no I don't know I feel like
every other character is more
interesting than Jonah I mean the the
side characters definitely like yeah is
the main character that should have been
yeah yeah neutrality is like carries the
whole thing and then the other boys are
a bit more you know he feels like he's
kind of more jonathan-esque with like he
had a bit more character in the start
where he was kind of more conniving and
then he kind of drops it real quick when
Bridge riding turns out I I feel though
that's like a very common trade with
JoJo because like even in part one like
it just definitely is way more
interesting of a character than John
yeah
that was amazing see I hold that opinion
for part three because I thought Joe
throw is a bit more more of like the
more cleaner JoJo's you know bro yeah
just just the dude bro can you like can
do everything perfectly but like the
entire crew or part three is what sells
it for me it's like The Ensemble yeah I
agree I hated polaro for the first time
I watched it I wasn't a fan but kakuin
carried it for me
of course I loved Polaris right I know
people love him yeah and it was kind of
fun afterwards where I'm like yeah I
think I like it looking back yeah but if
I watched it again I think I would be
like no yeah no that makes sense that
makes sense
it's way too long way oh [ __ ] I'm
constantly impressed with the sheer
amount of stuff you watch I watch pretty
much everything
it blows my mind your schedule must be
stupid like how do you watch all this
and then you you review every movie that
I swear that comes out and then you
uploading twice a day you're streaming
all day are you like on second monitor
while streaming are you watching [ __ ] no
man I don't know I stay up late like
three a.m and I have been since like
college but I've always found like
there's always enough time as long as
you're having fun yeah time moves for me
like time moves slower when I'm having
fun so I feel like I have more time to
do [ __ ] yeah because I swear to God you
watch more anime than like most of us
also you review more anime yeah
you're definitely running like anime
YouTube
because you're doing that on top of
everything else you're doing right yeah
yeah I would like to know your secret
because I've been watching like doing
anime as a job for like [ __ ] five
years now and I'm like struggling at
this point because it's just just so
much [ __ ] it's all coming out at once
too which is a little rough because
you're having because like it's all
coming from different places like
Netflix size JoJo's part six and they've
got a terrible release schedule yeah
admitted overlaps with other [ __ ] that
have come out seasonally yeah so it's I
don't know it gets convoluted yeah but
because you like reviews so many
different pieces of media I gotta ask
how does anime fans rank in terms of
like toxicity compared to like gaming
movies TV shows I've always wanted to
know maybe at the bottom oh really
really fans even when I have a take they
don't like even JoJo's it's like a
couple jokes I this is we're gonna
reopen an old wound I didn't mind the
newest Terminator the one where they
just like killed John Connor off right
because like it was just fun goofy
actions like John Connor like absolutely
[ __ ] sucked and Genesis true
mentioned salvation yeah three bad I'm
fine killing him off
I got so many Reddit threads and tweets
about how [ __ ] wrong I was even with
JoJo's no one's doing that
the new Terminator movies like some kind
of text like uh laundering no one that
like they're bad like they've been bad
for a while but the new one I think it's
dark fate or something with yeah Arnold
Schwarzenegger like has a brief
appearance yeah I didn't even know
they're still making them they looked
Dreadful it looked terrible I went to
see it because I thought it would be bad
because Genesis was an unwatchable dog
[ __ ] mess it was terrible but I went to
see it and I was like I don't mind it
it's nothing but this new Terminator
this lady killing you know the basically
same Terminator from Terminator two yeah
yeah it was fun yeah I think you're
gonna say the gaming fans are the most
talks no it's absolutely the movie fan
TV shows gamings Gaming's rough but
movie and TV shows they get rabid so the
terminated I think the worst thing that
ever happened Terminator was bad there
was an entire YouTube channel they did a
two-hour podcast dissecting how wrong
we should make this two hour podcast
dissecting their podcast
they were so mad it was wild no one else
has done that anywhere for gaming for
any
that's so weird to hear because you know
I see some of the [ __ ] like you know
donkey gets when he basically reviews a
jrpg and I'm like I'm glad I don't have
to deal with those you know it must be
just like a something with donkey they
don't like him in particular his takes
are spicy on jrpgs for sure but like I I
mean I have spicy takes on gaming too
like Red Dead Redemption I think is a
bit overrated
second one Red Dead Redemption too like
I think it's a bit overrated it's a
great game but the gameplay is dated
yeah needlessly tedious like it's a
great game but I think it is already
people get like mad for a minute but
they're like whatever I still like the
game yeah they don't do that for movies
and TV they don't it's like if you don't
like it you're [ __ ] up and here's why
see because I feel coming from like the
inside the anime Community I feel that's
what the anime Community is like to us
where it's like you say one opinion and
they will hold on to that [ __ ] for the
rest of your life yeah yeah and that
will never let you go for it I mean it
depends on the anime because JoJo yeah
we are like Jojo fans are very very loud
yes I feel like I think they have a
sense of humor though yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah they know they're annoying I
mean it's JoJo you go of course you guys
are self-aware you watch JoJo you know
of course but like I feel like
especially with like I've seen way more
talks and seeing something like the more
mainstream anime like Attack on Titan
fans they used to be like really chill
and then ever since like season three
season four and then it got mainstream
yeah basically basically right when when
they go like super super popular yeah
that's when I saw like the toxicity just
like [ __ ] skyrockets yeah I don't
know it's it's it's super weird and I'm
not sure what like gaming fans are like
as well does toxicity perhaps have to
correlate with how mainstream something
is
profound
the more mainstream something is the
more toxic yeah I mean but then I feel
like a lot of people just then it gets
you that it becomes so matter right
where then people will make a whole big
deal about complaining about this tiny
group of people yeah they're just the
bigger group of the ones complaining
about the annoying yeah a toxic things
and then it becomes this whole self like
fulfilling prophecy kind of [ __ ]
where it's like yeah you just Rick and
Morty fans were a little bit annoying
but they weren't that bad like everyone
made them out to be it was like one
Reddit post and they ran with I don't
know why everyone
they like ruined Rick and Morty you
can't what you can't say you watch Rick
and Morty now otherwise you're like oh
okay Ah that's so funny
yeah it was okay I thought it's been
fine it's been a watchable it's been
okay it's fine it's good it's better
than the Simpsons like what am I going
to do yeah do you have any other like
hot anime takes then let's bring them
all out while yeah yeah so since we're
going down the hot anime takes why not
give like probably the hottest I I hated
one piece for the first for the at least
the first 80 90 episodes okay okay big
big mistake you'll first of all you're
watching
I've heard uh does it get good so I met
I finished Alabaster I'm at Skype here
now it's much better like it's
definitely improving where am I at yo
before Alabama
yeah okay um did you like Alabaster
Alabaster was much much better that was
the first time I was like this is much
better yeah but let me go ahead and
explain this go on I hate absolutely
hate that they don't kill any characters
I think that is so silly like Pell takes
a bomb up into this how far are you in
Alabaster you can say yeah okay you can
say it there's been like moments where
I'm like okay like there was um I can't
remember it was the awk before it was
when they're on the giant Island whiskey
Peak yeah and there was this whole like
it was it was the I was I was been
reading the manga and I hadn't really
got with any of it I was kind of like
just I was like okay I know it's going
to get better yeah but that was one fire
I was like yeah this feels really dated
and like it made it feel really old when
they were like fighting with the wax
thing
there's a whole thing where they were
just stuck in wax and it was just like
what is this fight this is yeah well I
mean you also have to understand it's a
20 year old well right right it's like
you you read one piece and it feels old
like yeah it feels like a dated manga
because it would never you could never
have a manga this slow paced yeah like
come out today well that's why I'm
surprised you're actually watching it
because as a one-piece fan even I
wouldn't like advocate for watching One
Piece anymore it's the the anime is so
old now and so like slow paced it's back
in the day when it was like acceptable
just to have like filler everywhere to
just drag things on for as long as
possible yeah because there was only
like what maybe 20 new series per year
but yeah back then so people were like
more I guess like patients I mean like
[ __ ] older you know like first or
second season of Dragon Ball episodes
is so incredibly slow it's insane like I
can't I can't imagine me being like five
years old being like this is the most
high octane [ __ ] ever if you're watching
now it's just like two big Bros just
standing there staring at each other for
20 minutes it's like nothing's [ __ ]
happening yeah I think a lot of the
reason why people would get angry at you
for that too because I think one piece
fans have got so far you know it's like
looking at this child they look at Rose
tinted glasses like yeah no I love that
as a kid how can you not like it and
you're like I love this thing so much
now there's no way the start could have
been bad yeah right because it's like I
I this is because people who like one
piece really really like one piece and
it's like their identity and they it's
everything they're obsessed with I mean
the fact that they are like 20 plus
channels that can make a living off just
talking about one piece like name
another property where you can have that
like no no there's like two channels
bleach there's like 10 there's like okay
I'm dialing it back there's there are a
lot of channels who just cover the manga
yeah talk about the show of fan theories
who can who only do that and can make a
living yeah and there's room for more
than like 10. it's crazy like no other
anime you can do that or video Maybe
video game you can actually that's
League of Legends or something yeah I
mean I mean there's something yeah
there's some video games that are just
like they've approached as well yeah
exactly exactly I mean the one piece I
feel though
I feel like one piece is just like now
on a completely different caliber that
like it's it's very difficult to like
compare it to other manga series it's
pretty more accomplished in the Bible in
Japan like I I mean obviously it has
because I think I think it's like being
close if not already the top selling
like comic period yeah yeah like beating
out like even like Batman and Superman I
think which is like which is insane
insane to think about that it's it's
[ __ ] one piece you know you think
about how iconic Batman and Superman is
like in terms of like volume sold one
piece is getting up there yeah
um but yeah I mean like the fan base are
very very dedicated
their very lifestyle it is a lifestyle
you don't read like you don't read a
thousand volumes or not I don't see it
as part of your identity unfortunately
yeah but I'm excited to see what you
think of like future arcs though I know
where it goes because my girlfriend she
binged all of it she's caught up yeah
like a thousand something yeah so I know
where it goes and I really like where it
goes the journey to get there is [ __ ]
miserable oh yeah I'm really uh knowing
your JoJo takes now I'm like fully
expecting you to just have the hottest
one please
like yeah I thought sky island was the
best dog uh seven was kind of [ __ ] yeah
I do agree that it does feel like the
characters are a bit Invincible at least
in the start not only that though I feel
like they're not changing like Luffy's
exactly the same right now right
that's what I said but apparently I've
had they haven't changed I believe it
has been improving yeah I don't I still
don't like that no one dies like even
the I know like four major character
deaths I won't spoil anything yeah but
like you're past our law but it took
like a thousand chapters to kill exactly
like arlong doesn't die like arlong's
this terrible horrible man he gets
defeated by an ax kick never to be seen
again they talk about him like once or
something later on it's just that was
weird because like I remember reading
that part and I thought oh he's gonna
just pop pop back up because it doesn't
really feel like he was gone yeah and
then it just ended and I was like oh
yeah he didn't die he was incapacity
yeah yeah
to to counter it though it's a counter
it because I think because you know
since I've been a one-piece fan for a
long time I remember having the same
criticisms about one piece being like no
one no one seems to Die Why why there
are many opportunities for like a
character to die and then it just felt
like he was never gonna kill anyone off
and then when you get some of the first
major deaths you realize oh he's been
saving it for like this moment because
those moments like are [ __ ] iconic
and like anime and manga now and I think
yeah no I agree because I feel if you
have a manga that's going on for that
long especially yeah and you you've just
been constantly killing off characters
after the 20th death you're just going
to be like yeah all right what's the bet
he's probably gonna die again yeah so I
feel like it gets overdone yeah yeah
just thinking that you could make the
most iconic character there but it still
won't be more iconic than the Tokyo
Ghoul [ __ ] panel
and tell you know the phrase like that
you know this no you know I don't think
so yeah I only watched Tokyo Ghoul one
and two
oh no it's uh it's it's it's in the mall
that's always on Twitter I literally
yeah
it was so weird because I finally got
the context of that for the first time
and it's a really serious it's a really
really seriously but I like could not
take it seriously anymore because it's
just been I've just seen it so many
times it's like when you watch that
movie that you only know for the memes
and then you actually watch the scene in
context and you're like I know this is
supposed to be serious but I [ __ ]
hate that I can't take it seriously yeah
yeah yeah not worse but one thing I've
always liked about your anime videos and
your just videos about reviewing media
in general is that you always come
through it with the like uh such a like
a different lens from like how like
hardcore fan bases would view it like if
I see if I see review and Anime I know
I'm not just I'm not just gonna get an
anime Fan's perspective but someone who
just likes media in general you know and
I think uh you know I think I think
that's something that's really really
missing in the anime community in fact
because so many people in anime for the
longest time if you're an anime fan you
are nothing but an anime fan right do
you know what I mean you don't consume
any other medium yeah yeah right and I
think a lot of anime fans forget
especially anime is [ __ ] weird a lot
of the times I think we've just like I
think we've just just gotten used to a
lot of the weird [ __ ] that we can't like
even like pinpoint it yeah right it gets
it gets a little wacky I agree I I'm
very tired of the Trope of everyone's
like a middle schooler when it has no
place in it Tokyo Avengers I get is
based off of the guys like actual
experience but why the [ __ ] are they
still middle schoolers they could have
been adults it literally like made the
show like two points worse yeah
absolutely just because they insisted on
keeping them like 13. there's no reason
to like they're riding motorcycles their
parents aren't present like there's no
reason all the time you just look at the
characters and you're like you can't
tell me he's a 14. yeah there's
literally
seven foot gets stabbed and lives and
he's 14. [ __ ] off no yeah but isn't it
weird that we're okay we're not okay
with that when it comes to something
like Tokyo Avengers but if it's
something like Bucky we're like yeah
I think it was backing never asked you
to get invested in like a serious
emotional way God [ __ ] is so good it's
Sparky [ __ ] insane it's so silly I
think we've been saying we're like it if
if only it caught on a little bit more
it could easily be like that JoJo level
of show of like yeah they need to
increase the animation budget though I
don't know if you watch the recent ones
it's like very much like still images
that they shake a camera on yeah yeah if
you're going like JoJo's level of
Animation I swear it would be like as
popular oh I think yeah all right
Becky's done weird as [ __ ] than Jojo
I just love that Becky will do the
stupidest [ __ ] but it will deliver it to
you in the most serious narration it'll
be like this oh my God just just the
fact that he literally Powers up after
he loses that's the best thing in the
world how is that not like the most
iconic scene and his dad's just like
seeing this
that whole season was amazing I I can't
remember the big Mafia guy's name but he
comes up to him
they're at the river and he comes up
he's like your girlfriend does she want
to be a prostitute or something
well no I don't I don't think so and
then she's like getting really serious
like oh my God Baki like maybe I will or
whatever it was like such a weird scene
I remember watching that I was like this
this is amazing like this is absolutely
amazing and everyone forgets he's 14.
it's like eight feet tall it gets
revived yeah I'm drinking at like 10
liters of sugar water Japanese YouTuber
try to do it yeah yeah yeah yeah so have
you have you seen the the scene in
bakkie I think it's the second season
yeah where like he gets like poisoned or
whatever and he like gets really really
skinny oh yeah that was after the
slapping guy right yeah yeah and then
that tsukayo it gets like all right I
know how to revive him and he gets this
like 10 liter bucket of water and 10
kilograms of sugar and he's like drink
it and it somehow revives and then it
somehow revives him and I saw this
Japanese YouTube it was like I wonder if
you can do that in real life and so he
literally got like a bucket of water 10
liters put 10 kilograms of sugar in it
and started drinking it he maybe got
like one 50th of the way and just like
instant diabetes
oh my God yeah I noticed you do a lot of
like okay let's talk about Moby huge for
a second how did how did that become
like a meme I saw it on Amazon you saw
it on Amazon
wait wait what do you mean you still
just see that on Amazon well because
they give you like the recommended based
on things you bought and like I bought
dildos before usually from Adam and Eve
but Amazon had some weird stuff so I
bought from there they recommended Moby
huge at some point I was like wow that's
kind of nuts it turns out phase jev had
had one at some point so that I got to
see it in his video before ordering I
was like that's pretty good yeah yeah so
then 600 later got a Moby huge never
looked back it's great I gotta ask why
did you go through a phase of buying
dildo yeah so I I'm like oh I mean no
one you know no one else was brave
enough to test like what are they
capable of besides just like putting
them in your butthole like I needed to
see you know can we make a car out of it
yeah can we hit pinatas with it you know
like I had to test it I think that's why
people really enjoy your stuff it's like
you ask the questions that no one wanted
answers too afraid to answer
yeah maybe that's a better way of
phrasing it yeah have you ever thought
about buying some of like the weird [ __ ]
from Japan because there's a lot of
[ __ ] we bought an RV positor I don't
think it was from Japan though but
that's the egg oh what oh you guys don't
know what I'll be positives hey no it's
a uh so it's like a pseudo dildo but
it's really spongy and flexible and it's
like an alien weiner but it has egg
inserts so you can push like a lubed egg
through so when you insert it you can
put eggs into yourself which is pretty
cool so we got those
we got three we got it
do you remember what they were called
Danny I'm sorry to bring you in like
this but they had cool names it was like
the shakishu was
yeah the shakusha was like the long
morning this is like a fetish the floor
the floor was the great one
until like the egg being the the Avi
positor Community there's a community
was dishonest about the the floor
I'm fuming I'm gonna be a four-hour
podcast exposing
oh my God those were so cool and they
were great yeah so but like speaking of
which like you know including the Moby
Dick and everything um might be huge
like you what upload what twice a day
usually yeah but one of them is usually
just stream highlights yeah whether I'm
playing a game or going over like a
goofy topic and then the other one will
be a video I sit down like yeah so like
one one question I want to ask like just
as a fellow content creator is how do
you not get burned out I think it's just
from doing different things there was
absolutely a time like just doing game
playing commentary I'm like this is
getting kind of this you're still not
doing Halo right I started it back like
initially I started in 07 and it was
Gears of War all right so those were the
first videos I like made myself yeah and
then I it was Gears of War then I
transitioned Gears of War to Halo then
around 2010 I started doing fun tactics
for Battlefield which was the first
commentaries and then from there
gameplay commentaries that you know
always fun but started to get a little
also then started doing like infomercial
dubs I remember the information about
yeah so I just always kept trying to
spend new content to keep it fresh I
feel like if you stay in one Niche for
too long it gets a little stale
yeah yeah exactly yeah definitely been
there I mean his name's the anime man
and he doesn't watch anime anymore so I
haven't made anime content like over a
year yeah but I think that's the way to
do it though right like you don't want
to force yourself to make something no
like because it's not fun for the
audience it's not fun for you absolutely
but why two videos a day I I just have a
lot do you feel like [ __ ] I really want
to make this video but I just don't have
time to invest into it no I always have
plenty of time to do stuff like if it's
a bigger project always make sure to
allocate time bro please teach me yeah
right you must have like time management
skills when you say like bigger project
I should imagine bigger dildos
you're a bigger projects in the work
you're like making a seven foot deal now
yeah this one's out of marble
yeah if there's one thing I want to see
you make a video on uh It's featured in
one of Joey's video but you know what
Tango is yeah yeah so there's this Tango
that is basically like an Iron Maiden oh
my gosh that is basically like how how
heavy was it again it's uh 15 kilograms
so that's like what 25 30 pounds 30
pounds yeah yeah and it's basically it's
it's like it's like yeah like a steel
case for your Tango and the sole purpose
of it is so that you can work out while
you jack yeah
so it's like a shake weight almost yeah
like if you dropped it it would probably
yeah destroy your days
like Tenga has like so many like like I
did a video with gone where we tested
out like all the Tangers that they have
at the Tanga headquarters and they have
so many ways they have a vending machine
for him now don't they yeah yeah yeah
they have like mechs so like they have
the tango and it transforms into like a
Mac yeah it's like it's like it's like a
tank I don't I don't know but you can't
actually [ __ ] the Tango it's just it's
just like a toy that is in the shape of
a Tango that can turn into a Mac I don't
know why Japan is just you know he's
just one of those companies where it's
just like should we make it yeah yeah
the answer is yes yeah if the answer is
yeah
and I can respect that I can respect
absolutely absolutely but what's some of
like the weirdest Contraptions you've
like found because your dad makes some
weird Contraptions yeah so you've shown
that are in your studio right now yeah
so he's my dad likes to make goofy stuff
so he made the Moby huge into the
go-kart you guys saw that yeah he's made
the automatic ass wiping robot which it
doesn't work it just like peels your ass
off how does that work so you got a
rotating motor and he put like like a
scrubber on it so instead of toilet
paper it's just like a scrubber to scrub
your ass but it goes so fast that you
can't use it you'd hurt yourself I just
feel like a bidet solves this yeah he
does it just for the joke of it he
doesn't actually want to use them he's
like Sean I just I think uh yeah a few
more iterations
I think you should rename it to the
hamboard machine it's probably the one
thing you just shave like pieces
like your ass too fat all right get on
that baby
I don't know what the weirdest thing
I've ever seen would be though I'd have
to really think was there one thing
where you looked at and you're like this
is too weird to turn into a video yeah
uh so we it wasn't in the back building
I don't know if we got rid of it we had
32 pounds of [ __ ] and ass it was this
hold on giant hold on pause okay so
there's a place a local chain called the
Todd which is just you know normal sex
shop but they had something called 32
pounds of [ __ ] and ass yeah and it's
just this giant ass and [ __ ] and our
idea was to do a toilet paper tearless
by smudging chocolate on it and wiping
it to see like which was the most
absorbent it was Danny's idea and we
couldn't do it because the [ __ ] and ass
are like it's too fat like you can't
actually show it do you have this here
it's I think it's still there
right it's too dummy
with your hands it's this big it's like
like it would sit in your lap company
it's it's big it's gelatinous it Jiggles
here it makes cool noises like
oh it's like 80 bucks 80 bucks
oh okay was it what am I thinking of for
80 we definitely
some motherfucked up especially you'd go
to the store you just like [ __ ]
negotiating it like yeah this is the
best I can do best I can do is who else
is going to buy 32 pounds
I'll take six Ruby hugees right now 20
discount look at them out of your store
I'll take your entire stuff
all the sex children know you by name
locally yeah [ __ ] here he comes is this
just the [ __ ] that happens in Florida
yeah let me I'm sure the Todd sells
plenty they have lower ones like if
lower models they have 20 pounds of
[ __ ] and ass they have 10. like you
know they have small medium a large yeah
they have sizes but yeah I don't think
anyone's gone to the Wombo so whether
this obsession with like the sex toy
stop just because it just seemed fun
just because no one else was really
getting goofy with it I thought it'd
just be a fun fact you know YouTube
normally would crack down yeah what kind
of content get like age some of it does
some of it doesn't even get demonetized
but some of it does get age restricted
if you get like really egregious one of
the YouTube algorithm just thinks this
these items are I don't know like
they're throwing a small child around
yeah
like what does it think it is I'd love
to know what the machine is analyzing it
it's like yeah well that's a that's half
a human yeah they definitely don't
register it as a wiener
why would you shoot oh my God this
episode is sponsored by expressvpn you
know watching Netflix without using
expressvpn is kind of like paying for a
gym membership but only being able to
use the treadmill why would you live in
your Spire why would you do that it's a
waste of money waste of money but
luckily expressvpn can fix that
expressvpn lets you change your online
location so you can control where you
want Netflix to think you're located
they have almost a hundred different
server locations so you can gain access
to thousands of new shows plus this
works with many other streaming services
too like BBC iPlayer YouTube and a whole
lot more guys I've got a confession
unfortunately I am not yet nihongo josu
so sometimes I need anime with my
subtitles on but in Japan they don't
need that so I have to use expressvpn to
go in Crunchyroll or something so I can
watch anime with subtitles on and
expressvpn encrypt all of your data and
has the added benefit of encrypting your
data so you can browse the web securely
so be smart stop paying full price for
streaming services and only getting a
fraction of their content get your
money's worth at expressvpn.com trash
taste don't forget to use our Link at
expressvpn.com trash taste to get an
extra three months of free expressvpn
back to the episode I've been curious in
a completely unrelated to the sector we
can get back into that later if anything
comes out but I when you announce that
you were doing moist Esports I was like
damn that seems like a really hard thing
to break in yeah yeah so like how did
that all come about because I am
fascinated by that do you want to
explain voice yeah yeah sure it's a
moist Esports it's our Esports org so it
started kind of accidentally it's
something we've always wanted to do but
in August of last year a smash player by
the name of cola who had competed in our
tournaments and won them he hit me up on
Twitter he's like hey I'm lobbying for
Summit which is a huge Smash Bros
tournament he's like can you retweet
this and I was like bet but I'll do one
better I'll make a whole org around it
and really hype it up and then it
actually like he got in it actually
looked like you know Cola had a chance
of winning it which Esports can be like
a legitimate presence so then we ended
up signing Aaron which is another Smash
Bros player who's a friend Nicola also
at Summit and we did really well and we
were like gotta keep this going so then
we just put our foot on the gas it's
super hard to get into because it's so
expensive yeah I was kind of sad but the
one thing is that you know the reason
why a lot of these uh the uh what are
they called the I don't know Esports
agencies organizations yeah I mean
they're all venture capital right yeah
hundreds of millions of dollars because
they just bleed money it's just Imaging
money for ever basically I think I don't
remember exactly but I think it's only
two of them are profitable right now and
it's not from their Esports it's 100
thieves because of all the merch they
pump yeah I believe the other one was
TSM yes TSM because they have like a
massive fan base that goes all the way
back and no other Esports agency they're
just money no they're all bleeding money
I'm sure there's some that maybe make
profit here and there but for the most
part you're bleeding about it sounds
like a bobble well it's I think for
those like for companies that try and
like get into the Esports scene to try
and like because there's a huge multiple
because everyone wants to be in there so
they try and build it for three years
sell it for like I think it's like a 10x
multiple right now so they'll try and
make like a big exit with a big influx
of cash right I think for them it's
definitely more of like bubbleish maybe
even like a bit of a scam on their end
because you're doing it just to sell it
like you're kind of misleading everyone
yeah for us we just love the space yeah
so we're in rocket League now we're in
Apex we're in Split gate Smash Bros
Guilty Gear brawlhalla like it's just
really fun things to watch because for
us we do it for the content like the
watch parties are fun to watch so even
though it's massively negative in terms
of financial gain the content I think is
priceless yeah I guess when you say it
like that it's like what better way to
get into a bunch of Esports than just
have your team to root for exactly yeah
literally all of them yeah yeah 100
watching the chat like spam moist
Esports emotes and like talk about them
like it's so great it's super fun oh
that sounds like so much fun because
yeah because like me and kind of a big
league watches yeah yeah we don't play
it we don't play it just just for the
record
we don't play it but we love to watch it
and I know there's a big problem right
now where most of like the North
American organizations they like over
they overplay no overpay they play a
salary like like it's so inflated right
um and the players suck you know yeah
unfortunately it is unfortunately like
uh like the organizations don't perform
well internationally at all but they're
like the players just like the salaries
just keeping things when you're a good
player you go to America to retire yeah
because you get the paycheck right I
think across all Esports American
players get paid the most yeah like
across the board yeah it's it's a lot
yeah yeah but like I guess I think
you're going about it the right way
where it's just like a fun branding
thing as well yeah you just sometimes
you just want to get fun do something
fun in the space you know yeah I'm sure
eventually like with merch and we just
got skins in rocket League like I'm sure
it won't always be like a huge massive
Financial loss like right now it's all
out of pocket but maybe at some point it
starts to be self-sustaining yeah are
you really deep into the financial side
or are you more like a hey I just want
to do this someone else handled the
money part
so I don't really
I'm not like hands on with the finances
I know what's going on I absolutely
your financial advisors like hey Charlie
I don't know what's going on man but
this seems like a bad
so pretty much all of like my twitch
Revenue goes right into moist Esports at
this point it's just pretty much all
filters there to keep it all sustaining
because I've been sure the whole you
made the video about the Omega Strikers
of this cool thing where they said that
I I don't know how the tournament
functioned the how did it work people
could play for your team yeah so like in
the game you go in you choose what team
you want to play for there's like me
Reagan was the other big one from Brazil
Lily Peach who had a team yeah dyrus had
a team yeah you just go click I'll
compete for your team every win you get
com accounted for them whoever had the
most wins after 10 days got the first
prize which was three percent of the net
revenue of the game which is a crazy
offer yeah so we went Hog Wild on I saw
the results and it was like 10 million
uh 2 million and it was like okay I
think uh I think you won yeah I mean
that could have that was awesome it was
it's a fun game too like it could amount
to no money or it could amount to some
but it seemed like an opportunity worth
it because yeah fun game and it could
lead to something that helped moist the
Esports yeah because I think you
mentioned your video right that you
mainly recently want to do is you're
like hey all this money's gonna go into
moist Esports yeah I mean that's just
crazy like it seems like a like a
colossal undertake it is it's a lot to
get into the field like do you see it
making money like profitably in like the
next five years or is that like even
even further down the line five years
hopefully like yeah five years a long
time to keep going yeah it'd be nice
within five years but obviously are
there any more games you want to get
into in terms of like Esports that you
want to bring under yep so we've been
looking a lot at like CS go valorant
kind of shot themselves in the foot with
their whole franchising I don't know if
you guys know about that but yeah he
just hates veteran periods I think it's
like the most boring thing to watch yeah
I'm a fan to watch I don't play anymore
yeah yeah but yeah like all the big ones
League of course is a pipe dream but
that's super expensive yeah on their
spots like 15 20 million yeah it's a lot
it's that's 100 months ago
yeah what do you think makes like a good
esport because it seems like when
whenever a new Hive game gets released
now everyone's like okay when's the
Esports you know when's Esports starting
the OverWatch League was like a I mean
they manufactured it right yeah and then
that kind of crashed them behind it so
bad it was 20 million dollars just to be
in it it was so dumb and I remember
because I because I liked OverWatch when
it first launched and I was like okay
let's try watching the esport of this
and I just could not follow it is a
miserable esport I think it's a [ __ ] it
just wasn't fun it was two tanks
everyone's just shooting at tanks
forever yeah then dump alt rinse and
repeat it wasn't a funny Sport and
there's like no time to explain I think
league has that perfect balance as a
spectator sport where there's enough
breathing breathing room where you can
kind of explain things if a friend's
watching with you or you know you can
kind of talk through it and the games
are long they're like 40 minutes and
it's very obvious when something is
happening yeah whereas in OverWatch
you're like I don't know what the [ __ ]
is happening Genji killed my whole team
and I'm like how do I explain this like
so you could have reset every time he
kills right but then Anna role to
empower him and so like it's like
actually it's pretty cool it's like what
like it doesn't make sense if you don't
know the game I think for esport to be
like hype to watch it's got to be fast
paced and it's got to be something you
can look at knowing nothing about the
game and understand yeah so rocket
League's perfect for that I mean it's
soccer yeah cars yeah you know exactly
what you're looking at yeah
it's pretty easy as well just like any
fighting game yeah it's two players in a
fighting game most of the time they
fight each other you know exactly yeah
yeah and fighting Esports seems the most
hype it's like the crowds oh my God
there's just the community in general
just they just like I don't want to get
into fighting games just to be a part of
this community
they are massively hype
just seeing the crowds like scream and
jump around whenever anyone's doing
anything and it's literally Pikachu
fighting Julie possible yeah and people
are losing them
this is so surreal when you sit back and
think about it but like it's awesome
it's just like the perfect level of
toxicity as well yeah it's just like
everyone [ __ ] talking so nobody takes
anyone seriously exactly which other
Esports had that in a way that where it
was it worked but I guess because
fighting games just had it from the
ground up right that is one-on-one so
they can talk [ __ ] to each other whereas
it's like 5v5 it's much harder to start
talking yeah yeah because everyone you
see an interview in league and it's just
like like 90 of interviews are like the
most boring generic PR interview of all
time and then you see funny game
interviews and that's just like
everyone's talking [ __ ] it's so much fun
it's so much better yeah and like the
memes that come out of it as well I just
think like the fighting game Community
oh my God all like the compilations that
come out of like this first tournaments
this year is the best award salty Smash
Bros
compilation 15. it's so good I think the
only thing in my mind that makes
fighting games uh like not a great uh oh
my God I mean it's good spectating but
like on the level that like let me let
me hear you just because it's over too
fast they're fast so like when you get
like a street fighter attacking those
games can go by in a single combo and
it's like you know you watch League you
can go to the toilet you can come back
and maybe you miss something maybe you
didn't but in fighting games if you miss
it or you you went out to get some
snacks from the store like the bracket
is totally changed and like it's hard to
follow the characters and then like you
know you can build up these teams in
longer form games and longer tournaments
yeah whereas you know in fighting games
you get knocked out and then it's like
okay well my guy's gone I definitely I
don't really know who like Cheetos xx4
is and like yeah yeah you know it's it's
I feel like the story lines aren't there
as often like the way that they could
because you can manufacture it more yeah
I feel with something like Evo they do a
good job with like yeah yeah you know
creating this because when you have
people who come back time and time again
then you can make stories yeah yeah
right you have like the the top 10
players who are normally at most events
then you can start making the narratives
right yeah and if they're there a lot
then it works yeah
um but even then it's over in minutes
well I think the difference is that
something like League you know you have
organizations you know no yeah fighting
games is very much here is the
individual player yeah it's only like
one-on-one so it's like far easier to
follow The Narrative of this
organization like you do with like
traditions for sure it works yeah yeah
especially Sports yeah story arc
we have a great story I think so yeah
are you think aside from Esports are you
thinking of do you ever think you're
going to get into like any other
business or any other field well I mean
you're also what you did the comic right
yeah we're still working on it
absolutely insane I feel like you're
you're doing so many massive things all
at the same time yeah and it's like
crazy to see especially with the two
videos a day plus streaming it's like
you'd never think the guy who buys six
giant dildos is like a Saturday I'm just
trying to like a French chat you know
it's like it's it's awesome it's it's
firing honestly is this the lucky
position to be in to do those things
like those are all dream things like
doing the comic book doing the Esports
org and stuff like that it's just things
I've always wanted to do so to be able
to do it is just I love doing it is
there like anything else you like really
want to like take off the bucket list
that you can say on camera
um you gotta make a whole show yeah that
we definitely want to do that we've been
we've been working on our Netflix pitch
which will hopefully be coming up
sometime soon hell yeah hell yeah uh do
you wanna do you want to explain your
comic book to the fans yeah so godslap
is something we started a few years back
so Matt Danny Jackson and I created it
it's just this really goofy like
cyberpunk-esque world where people are
slapping the [ __ ] out of each other
there's without giving too much away
there's there's some villains like the
Fister who they maybe use his his fist
as opposed to an open car
and basically it's the adventure of as
finding his place in that world right
now as well as eventually squaring off
with that guy that's the art we're
currently on I think by the time this
comes out the second the animation thing
hopefully so right now the reason we've
had issue two done for a while but we've
had a problem with like paper shortages
and everything because everything's in a
shortage so it's a little out of our
hands at the moment but hopefully so how
did the audio come about
the slapping videos
I I think it was it wasn't right after
that either because Jackson was talking
about like some dumb Star Wars [ __ ]
because he's a big Star Wars fan I was
like Jackson's is stupid you know what
would be cool slapping
I we just started talking about slapping
and this was right after like the
biggest one I think it was Vasily versus
a Lesh right that was massive yeah like
I remember when you covered the slapping
videos I would just see a video we have
10 million views oh it was such it's
such a fun sport I was like what the
[ __ ] is this it's the most eastern
European sport I've ever seen because
it's like I feel like Eastern Europeans
are not happy unless someone is near
diet yeah no it's like I was surprised
there wasn't like glassing incidents of
like slamming their head on like an
actual pint or something crazy it was it
went hard so when is one of them getting
sponsored by moisties
one of the first like someone's gonna
die from that slapping someone did die
no really yeah and is actually one of
the biggest guys in the scene his name
was valus uh Artur values wait what
happened you got slapped or die so the
champion zalesh slapped him so hard that
he lost Consciousness briefly but he
came to his brain started hemorrhaging
they had to rush him out and he was put
into a medically induced coma and he
didn't make it holy [ __ ] oh my God if
you if you look at the guy though you
would never expect someone like him
could even be pierced by a bullet like
he was one of the biggest men I've ever
seen I'm guessing I didn't like halt the
Esports at all
no I'm pretty sure they actually had to
stop okay that Division I think had to
stop because I haven't seen them do
anything like that since that was their
big like big tournament that that
happened it'd be pretty bizarre it
seemed kind of like a less lesser of an
organized sport more of a we have this
big guy who wants to try and slap him he
is currently the champion yeah yeah it
was very much these are [ __ ] freaks
and they're gonna slap each other it
definitely seemed like kind of like a
circus yeah
almost like he's a guy and you get a
hundred dollars now the US the US won
slap fight Championship that one
actually is like one run like a real
sport like they do drug testing they
have they have this thing where like if
you get knocked out three times you're
just out because they don't want CTE
like they I didn't even know there was
an American yeah slap fight Championship
is the American League oh my God it it
feels way more dangerous than like boxes
it is because you can't defend yourself
yeah
yeah right
I don't know it's terrifying it is the
thought of doing that oh my God you
cover like a lot of like little
underground sports like this though like
apart from slapping what are some of
your other favorites oh my God anyone
here a fan of backyard wrestling
please please explain this is this is as
American as it gets very Floridian no
this is this is very American backyard
wrestling it's it used to be much bigger
than it is now but it's unauthorized
unsanctioned wrestling events
you just get like a bunch a lot of times
you get like some inbred people you get
a ring they get shared specifically
makes them have no pain just
traditionally you'll get some like
actual wild people going crazy so they
get chairs and then eventually as it
ramped up in the early 2000s they come
it came up with combat zone wrestling
czw and that's when they used like real
barbed wire real baseball bats and they
were just beating the [ __ ] out of each
other yeah and calling it wrestling they
jump off of roofs on top of each other
land on grass not even a ring that's
just like some old style [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah and there's one in particular they
were on YouTube I don't know if they are
anymore it's called p-o-r wrestling and
I'll never forget this stunt they wanted
to go so hard they had one of them get
hit by a moving like an actual speeding
vehicle so they of course it's wrestling
so they script everything so they're
like slapping each other yeah hits them
with like a toilet seat the guy's
stumbling and then a car comes in it's
going like 30. it's going at least 30.
blessing absolutely [ __ ] glasses he
flies over the car lands on the ground
and he's out I've never seen him again
he may have died I'm not sure never saw
him again
because it was hype
it was going 30 at The Spectators too
because they had an audience at The
Spectators doesn't hit me one and just
blast that guy they were so proud they
did it again a month later but this time
through a motorhome so they had two
people wrestling on top of a like a
motorhome trailer crashes the car going
30 again through the motorhome at The
Spectators hits a tree it is so cool
he's making money they don't they make
zero dollars they're just destroying
they just love it yeah the love of the
sport I thought the DDT Japan was like
crazy wrestling no you guys have you
guys have like a backyard wrestling
subsidiary I think like something very
similar all right I don't know what it's
called I filmed a video with um DDT that
like typically The Crazy Ones the one
who do those fights with the dolls the
sex dolls oh those are awesome yeah I
went to one of those shows it's just so
weird it was like it was a half comedy
show half wrestling yeah yeah acrobatics
there's this whole bit where these guys
just got naked and shut their ass like
going in like rotation three of them in
someone's face nice
and then smashed a plastic Ikea box on
him and it like fully shattered and it's
just like what is this like this that
sounds amazing but then they
legitimately have insane very good
talented wrestlers like the main show
but then they have like lower down they
have kind of like I don't know I mean
it's I don't even know what to describe
it like more show Show clown shows uh
but like one of the guys who I filmed
with he's he's a aew now and he's like
doing really well okay yeah yeah he's
got pretty funny yeah I think one of my
favorite videos I've seen recently which
is something I didn't know existed in
this day and age was it was a
documentary about the bare knuckle
boxing scene yeah yeah which like the
only reason I knew he exists what's
wrong yeah the vice one did you see that
one yeah I saw that one yeah that's I
[ __ ] love that video it was like a
debt collector yeah I'm a champion from
Liverpool yeah yeah here's some
Newcastle oh yeah and they were building
up to this like final event because
there's this bare knocker boxing
champion in England right and then
someone from America like that's I think
it was a champion for America flew over
to fight him in England yeah a new
Challenger approaches right and so they
build up this massive Advantage follows
like both of their stories and you see
the American and he's like perfectly
chiseled would you know he's exactly how
what you think a bare knuckle boxer
should look right and then there's this
guy from [ __ ] Newcastle right who's
got like this [ __ ] massive beer
drinking and eating like yeah
he was like you know he has like a
proper beer belly he's drunk most of the
time and so we get to like the day of
the fight and then the Americans uh the
American is there on time ready to fight
and the guy from Newcastle is like two
hours late or something because he's
like he's he's been he's been drinking
he's been drinking like before and then
he shows up in this taxi [ __ ] drunk
out of his mind stumbling into the ring
and he [ __ ] wins this fight it's
[ __ ] us it's one of the most British
things I've ever seen in my life it's
literally it literally felt like a guy
originally movie oh my God if you
haven't watched that video please watch
it it's one of my favorite videos I've
watched recently it's a vice documentary
on it I think it's a vice wild bro yeah
up north now what are they doing Florida
that's one thing I wanted to ask
actually like how do you like stumble
upon these like kind of very like weird
underground like Niche you just get a
lot of people's messages yeah usually
people tell me about something silly
going on like telephone booth boxing is
Big right now okay hold on what is that
it's so it's a Russian sport I believe
they get two you guys going to a
telephone booth and they just start
boxing one inside
900 different ways to fight each other
yeah it's cool too like they don't hold
back either they go [ __ ] wild in that
telephone booth and then people like
tweeted me like oh this looks like
something Charlie would like and then
I'll check it out yeah you're right
basically yeah what else any other weird
[ __ ] that you like I'm sure there's some
other [ __ ] up [ __ ] I've found so many
weird communities there's this isn't a
community it's one guy but there's a guy
whose entire channel is built around
sitting on things wearing tight pants so
he sits on like hot lunches and birthday
cakes oh I remember I've seen this guy
it's [ __ ] weird it is he just like he
doesn't even do anything sexually sits
on it and then maybe they like moves a
little bit of the cake one yeah yeah is
it like for review purposes no no it's
like silent right yeah I think it's got
to be a fetish but he doesn't even do
anything sexual he just like sits on
food I don't know he sits on an orange
and one of them
I'm interested
is that really a community but I mean
he's kind of cool
he's making the community man he's
building it I like to imagine that
there's like a secretly written
Community for this black guy I don't
like the way that he sat on that orange
I really wish he'd changed the angle of
that guy
his ass isn't firm enough
so did you go did you grow up in Florida
I've been here my whole life yeah so as
someone who is outside the US you know
we hear about Florida basically through
the internet yeah is it as crazy as the
internet portrays it as I I've always
wanted to know it's hard to say like I
definitely know of like really Florida
weird [ __ ] like even here in Tampa and
I've mentioned this guy a lot he used to
be called the Ebor shoe licker
there's a place there's a place in Tampa
well South from here called Ebor and
there's a guy there who built himself up
like a big reputation for licking
people's shoes on the street so the guy
just sold money no for fun so he hangs
out he's just on the street okay and if
you walk by him he'll ask if he can lick
your shoe and you expect like I imagine
you guys are picturing he like licks the
top of your shoe or something yeah he
looks the bottom of your shoe from
bottom to top in like one fell suit
what does he get out of it he just likes
it I don't know I don't know he just
likes it and that's like a Florida
staple yeah well that's a Tampa state
there
they knew as well the senator he in Ebor
as well there's a place called The
Castle right and the guy this his name
was the senator he would go there he'd
go in like a g string but he'd always
pop Viagra so he'd go like chubbed to
this club to dance and get wild and
wacky
yeah like there are those things that
exist here but I on a normal daily basis
don't see too much Florida [ __ ] you know
because obviously you like I said you've
been in Florida your whole life did you
see a progression where you got more
weird over the years or is it always
kind of been kind of odd to me it's
always just less documented yeah I think
just less documented I think because
Florida has like very open law where
it's like anyone who gets arrested it's
all public you can come check it out
they have videos usually so it's always
nice
hey did you see the new batch
come look at all the wild [ __ ] happening
in Florida guys here in this week's
Florida
new arrests just drop check it out
that's crazy I mean I guess that's where
the whole like Florida man thing started
right 100 it's weird
um I know in where I'm well I was born
and raised there's a weird public roster
of all the criminals and when they
commit them they'll have the mug shot
like this is what this guy did really
and like in like very not like plain
language and very like opinionated
language bizarre yeah yeah it's yeah
it's weird
because you're from were you from a
small town you're like oh nothing bad
happens and then you you read this
you're like oh bad stuff happens yeah
okay I I definitely just didn't know
it's weird this episode is sponsored by
PC specialist Black Friday sales are now
live at PC specialist guys with
pre-built systems available at a
discounted price for a limited time only
do you want more customization but like
me not confident in building a PC
yourself don't worry build your next
Generation gaming PC with PC specialist
easy to use custom configurator do not
let Joey build a PC please get PC
Specialists to do it please help me
please plug it in the motherboard he
will not use the graphics card so guys
whether you're a gamer Enthusiast
content creator or just Joey PC
specialist has got you covered with a
wide range of components to choose from
to suit any budget for your need messy
wise inside your PC will be a thing of
the past as PC Specialists nearly cable
managers then thoroughly test each order
to ensure stability and performance
thank God all of their PCS are powered
by Windows 11 playtime anytime so get
yours now by visiting pcspecialist.st
slash trash taste and using our code
trash for a discount at the checkout or
smash that link in the description down
below back to the episode I'm curious
because I recently in the past like year
or two got like super addicted and super
into twitch how did you like you get
into it because I as far as I've ever
been on Twitch and watched it you've
always been streaming on it so I started
on Justin TV in 2010.
so did you have that thing where it
automatically transferred you no because
I took I took a six year break I
streamed in 2010 and I stopped at the
end of 2010 okay and then I picked it up
again in 2016 but I was on YouTube and
then I switched to Twitch in 2018. right
Justin TV slapped though were you guys
ever on Justin TV
it was great Justin TV had like 24-hour
reruns of like Angry Video Game Nerd
four player podcast oh yeah it was so
wild back then you it didn't have a rule
you weren't allowed to stream non-gaming
stuff as well no Justin TV was anything
goes twitch started as only gaming yeah
and they changed after a while yeah then
they eventually added the IRL category
yeah that's right yeah because Justin TV
was the original streaming yeah and then
because there were so many people
streaming games they were like let's
make a separate uh separate website just
for that just for that everyone else
streams on Justin.tv they didn't really
all get moved over and then eventually
got moved over because uh Justin.tv got
shut down
they got bought out yeah oh yeah they
did they did it's like a tamagotch is
going on
sorry okay
Joey give him the belt he's asleep now
it was just like I need to go to bed
it's fine I'm curious what do you think
of all the uh the twitch stuff they
recently did oh yeah oh there's the
splits and everything splits and a few
other things they did I mean obviously
they changed kind of change the rules on
gambling uh we see it's a little better
it's a step and right direction I think
oh it's definitely a step
um but yeah I mean what do you think
where twitch is going it shows a very
clear lack of like understanding the
platform and the streamers yeah like
this was a point Ludwig brought up in
one that I think is super true twitch is
super bloated they have so many
Engineers but I can't name anything
they've put out that is good in the last
like five years like elevated chats are
dog [ __ ] I think we can all agree
[ __ ] it's terrible like they don't
understand they don't do anything
temperature yeah but but it goes under
the stream most of the time so you can't
see it as a streamer what yeah it's an
elevated Jet doesn't elevate it goes
under your stream and you never see it
it's a complete scam I think I think
they want to get people to not donate
yeah I think they're trying to stop
people from getting donations because
twitch doesn't get a cut of it oh no
it's like why would we do that when we
can't take 50 right yeah yeah I I yeah
like you said it seems bloated and also
it it's odd I remember seeing a few
articles that obviously they replaced a
lot of the staff and slowly it became
you know less uh focused on like the
community and more about the business
side of it which obviously is good in
some senses but others it's like all
right this is a clear message of what
they're looking for but they just don't
know how to do it right like because you
would think the last thing you'd want to
Target is the streamers because I looked
it up recently 76 of all twitch traffic
comes from the top one percent of
streamers yeah yeah which and I think
expanding further it was like 99 of all
twitch traffic comes from the point one
percent of top streamers yeah which most
of the top streamers are on the 73rd yep
almost all of them like pretty much
everyone on that leak is in the 70 30
split so targeting them pushes them to
maybe go to YouTube where it is 70 30.
yeah and they usually get a bag for the
switch Yeah like twitch should be that's
like the last resort taking from the
streamers they should go for like we
have a million Engineers maybe we start
making some Cuts here instead they're
not doing anything it's odd I I don't
really know what that objective or goal
with it is yeah I guess we'll see I
don't know it just has to be like short
term
or something it's like what are they
gonna do next I guess which is kind of
the worrying have you thought about
going back to streaming on YouTube or
you're going to stay on Twitch for a
while I still think twitch is the better
platform at the moment I think it's
definitely the better live streaming
experience as a viewer absolutely
definitely definitely but if they keep
shoving so many odds in their face like
it's it's going to get beaten by YouTube
YouTube you skip the ads right like it's
better yeah as a streamer they keep
trying to
and it's just because then like when you
play a three minute ad it's a lot like
it's so much and it and it interrupts
the content it's not an ad break it's
like I'm still streaming I'm still doing
stuff and now I'm just annoying people
because they can't see it whereas if it
was an ad break no one would see
anything and everyone everyone is
understanding of the fact that nothing
is happening right so that's why the ads
are playing yeah and so I think that's
why it's frustrating uh yeah I remember
I had the automatic ads on oh that's
yeah because I had a I had a I had a
instead you know this twitch has this
automatic ads thing yeah yeah so I had
um someone from twitch this is a very
very long time ago they reached out to
me and they're like hey
um if you run these automatic ads it's
really good your viewers really enjoy it
because there's no more pre-rolls that's
the way they sold it to me and I was
like oh that makes sense yeah that's
good because if every every one minute
of ads
um for 10 minutes on your channel when
people click on it for the first time
there won't be a net right so if there's
an ad every 10 minutes for one minute
there'll be no pre-rolls but that that's
a lot of that
I turned it on and I very suddenly found
out that people hated it they were like
it's very backwards logic yeah because
what you forget is that yeah okay maybe
it's good at getting the initial
retention yeah when you actually go and
look at your stats people are normally
watching streams on average if you do
like a six hour stream people are
normally watching for two hours you're
right like it's a long time yeah and
that's a lot of ads to throw that way
especially if they're already giving you
five bucks a month you know like five
bucks a month for like maybe like the
occasional bits and you know donations
and stuff as well if they're really
dedicated it's like I'm not Netflix you
don't get a catalog I barely turn up
half the time five bucks a month for
that like and then I have to make you
sit through it at every minute yeah like
what like at least Netflix you get like
Rick and Morty
nothing else you get Arcane maybe a
Terminator movie
you get you know what I mean it's like
you're asking a lot so I it's
frustrating that they they kind of push
you towards this it might be I'm sorry I
asked this question I just used as a
vehicle the brand no I think it's a good
rant to have the ads are outrageous
they're putting way too much focus on
like incentivizing streamers to run ads
Yeah by taking that split away they keep
hyping up their ad incentive program to
make up for it right which is super is
coming and the ad incentive program
doesn't really make sense after you're a
certain size because the amount of money
they're going to give you for the amount
of intrusion you'd have to do is not it
doesn't make it it has a lot of really
really small streamers I think give them
an extra little paycheck but I just
don't take it like I've never looked at
it until once that it made sense yeah is
the Netflix category even still good uh
just what do you mean I don't know
Netflix category yeah I'm sorry yeah you
were talking about Netflix sorry
tangent you know Netflix even still have
a good catalog sorry that's what I meant
to say the thing is if you don't live in
the US yes like if you if you're outside
of the US there's pretty much no
competition think about it okay like in
the UK there's not really much do you
have HBO Max you can't get HBO Max we
can't get Hulu oh wow you can get Hollow
in Japan though but the catalog is [ __ ]
and and the the one thing that does suck
is that a lot of the time because of the
way that Japan does things like anime
will be on Netflix in Japan but because
of the deal there won't be English
subtitles so it's really frustrating
because if I swap to like if I was in
America it would have English subtitles
but they just take it off just for Japan
because of some licensing deal no
problems is fine some shows I really
need the subtitles yeah it's just it's
weird but yeah I think I don't know I
still watch a lot of Netflix I barely
watch Netflix anymore and I realized
this the other day actually I'm like
[ __ ] I'm playing I'm paying for a
subscription basically just for anime
and the anime catalog is like even like
yeah well I I watched uh on the on the
plane right over here they made a
documentary about the oh yeah you watch
documentaries
I'm a fan of documentary even if they're
dog [ __ ] like I just love seeing what
people think is good enough for a
documentary and seeing how they present
the story but lately there's been this
weird Trend and I don't know if there's
a few production companies that are
pumping these out where it was about the
GameStop stock oh nice it was a
documentary on that literally just came
out wow and um it's this category of
like all right we managed to get like
six relevant enough people to the story
to agree to an interview right from a
story that's already like well explained
and stuff and we'll make a a really
mediocre documentary about something
that you maybe heard about yeah and then
they spell it out and read dumb ways and
all the edits are really like how they
how they show social media and
documentaries and portray it is like
they can't just show a Facebook feed
they always have some dramatic kind of
angle of some fake Facebook feed and
it's always just looks terrible and and
the narrator's Annoying and it's always
a [ __ ] and this documentary about the
game's almost just awful I'd rather have
a 20 minute like video by uh
International yeah that's what I was
gonna say I was just like if I want a
documentary about the Game Stops well
it's from internet story yeah they spent
like a 20-minute story into a two-hour
thing where they like just they like
smash cut and they do this with
everything it's like True Crime uh other
stuff there's a few really good
documentaries on Netflix I think like
I'm told it's really good uh the uh
racing Jeffrey Dahmer one was that's
like more yeah it's like a full show
that's a show oh okay they have the
don't [ __ ] with cats documentary for
Netflix though if you saw that yeah yeah
I know I didn't finish it actually I I
thought it was decent
I like I thought the story was amazing
like the actual story itself
very pretentious and like annoying yeah
people they got to tell the story were
just really off-putting yeah really
annoying because that's important right
who the the narrator who's telling the
story or the voices that we're getting
at Food yeah I'd like to make or break
with the documentary and there's ways
you can use it well and there's ways you
can't like the what's the documentary
about that guy who's like a he's um he's
he's insane and he just lies all the
time and he pretends to be he used to
pretend to be like missing kids in
America oh I remember I remember this
documentary and so the whole documentary
is told from like his perspective and
he's telling you how what's happening
and what he did and and how it all goes
and then like right at the end they
throw you this twist where like they
just kind of make you realize that
you've been listening to this whole guy
tell you the story and that you just
took his word for everything and that
this guy is is an impulsive liar yeah
and so like they throw this bone right
at the end it just makes you think like
oh I think half the [ __ ] he just said
was just complete [ __ ] but you have
no idea yeah and it's so good
it's so good because it's like it I like
documentaries that make you question the
people who are talking and that's why I
like it when there's multiple sides in
the documentary yeah yeah but more often
not they only get one side and stuff
like that yeah basically what he was
pretending about was because there was
his family who had a who had a missing
child and that their child was like
missing for years and years and then
years later this guy uh pretended to be
their missing child right right and he
got away with it for like [ __ ] years
before people started like asking
questions yeah but when you're following
his perspective he starts throwing in
like little little questions to make you
question the family that took him in
yeah like the weird ones who were trying
to hide something yeah he may have seen
like oh maybe they murdered their kid
and they wanted to they'd be like oh my
God our kid turned up and that we
definitely didn't kill our other kids
yeah but the weird thing is is that this
kid that he was pretending to be was
from like Missouri the guy pretending to
be him was French
I know that I haven't seen the
documentary I know who you're talking
about though yeah he's like insane yeah
I know exactly who you're talking about
that and it's brilliant because it uses
this guy's like because he's really like
he's really well spoken he tells his
stories really well yeah and and it's I
love it when documentaries do this when
they like take the person and then like
by the way this guy might be full of
[ __ ] right and then they kind of use the
that's cool yeah it's really the guy's
story is pretty interesting even if it's
even if it's lies it's insane yeah like
it's so good that like it's worth the
watch yeah it's really good stuff
put the poster on screen you know
because it is it is a really good
documentary I highly recommend that
other one as well yeah like if you have
like that one documentary you watch that
just like blew your mind oh this is an
embarrassing one when I was a kid the
one that blew my mind was a very taboo
one it was called
was it Zeitgeist the one that was like
looking at religion is a scam 911 wasn't
inside job it's a conspiracy theory yes
yes
I was called Zeitgeist or something like
that right yes it was yeah it's
something like that and it was like it
was basically a 4chan video but they put
they put it on like uh like DVD and I
watched it and I was like whoa this is
nuts 911 was done by Bush
yeah I was like whoa they're making
crazy arguments the God's not real yeah
like I was blown away
holy [ __ ] that was like the one like I
guess that wasn't even a documentary it
really was how your friends about it I
did yeah did you know guys we didn't
actually lie yeah like crazy like I
legit had like the same thing happen and
I was like 12 because when you're 12 you
think that like people who make stuff
like movies or film must be correct
because they yeah and it's on DVD
because it's on DVDs it's on movies and
I remember I had this one I told the
story the podcast once but I uh we had
to do a school presentation and I just
watched it was like in front of like a
class of like 20. I just watched a bunch
of things about the moon landing
yeah I didn't believe it right I didn't
believe it and then there's like 911
stuff and you know the whole like wind
wing dings yeah yeah yeah you type in
like certain things on wingdings on
Microsoft Excel oh my God it's it's it's
proven that 911 was was uh it was like
uh fake obviously all [ __ ] so I went
to school I did this presentation and
what I expected to happen was my teacher
would be like you're a [ __ ] idiot
what the [ __ ] wrong with you my
teacher was like oh [ __ ]
dude the wing dings thing is
at the time I thought damn big brain
dude and then like days later my friend
was like dude you're a [ __ ] idiot
what did you watch I don't know some
random Youtube and I realized I just did
like a [ __ ] conspiracy theorist pitch
to like a bunch of 12 year olds and you
almost convinced your t-shirts I'm
pretty sure my teachers to this day
thinks that moon landing his face
probably from a 12 year old kid I'm like
if I was able to convince my like 20
something year old teacher the moon
landings were fake as a 12 year old I
don't think she should have been
teaching to be fair that I feel like at
age 12 or around there like as long as
you say something with absolute
confidence you're most likely to believe
it my dad trolled the [ __ ] out of me
with that kind of stuff when I was
little like oh my God your dad just like
what was it what was what did you
jealousy yeah so I said it on one of the
live shows but like uh my dad uh so our
family used to play like a little like
card games like you know like Solitaire
obviously but like a lot of like other
card game stuff like that and my mom was
really good at shuffling the cars like
she did like the whole like flicking the
wrist kind of thing and like pulling it
back and stuff bridging and stuff and
I'm just like you know as like a 10 year
old you're just like whoa that's sick
what the [ __ ] yeah and then my dad one
day was just like yeah do you know why
your mom's really good at shuffling it's
because she used to be a dealer in Vegas
and I believe that [ __ ] until like Age
19.
and and like and I would tell that to my
friends
your mom might be cool but uh my mom
used to be a dealer you're my Japanese
mom my Japanese
used to be a dealer in Vegas and then I
think it was like 19 or 20 or something
my dad was like son I have to kind of
come clean
um yeah your mom wasn't a dealer in
Vegas I lied to you this entire time and
I asked my mom about and she's like yeah
I've never even been to America
I don't know what your dad's talking
about and ever since then I'm just like
whenever I hear something or like
whenever someone tells me something in
the utmost confidence immediately my
mind's just like is it really though is
it really the first time I found out the
Lavender Town like copy pastors bro I
thought the kids going insane I was like
I listened to it oh my oh my god there
was like this whole thing where it's
like if you performs it played it
backwards or slow or something no no it
was it was a creepypasta which was you
know Lavender Town in the first Pokemon
game because all the Pokemon died yeah
like which is where like the the Pokemon
graveyard is yeah that theme song
apparently in the Japanese version they
used a certain frequency that only
children
changes could hear and apparently there
was like three or four cases of like
children between the ages of like five
and ten going insane listening to the
Lavender Town Theme from the original
Japanese version and people believe that
[ __ ] dude I believe that early Fortune I
only read it like lap that [ __ ] up being
like yo Nintendo's got a dark secret bro
when are they gonna come out about the
Dark Side of Nintendo and then you know
years later people realize it's just
that's the classic one the Rugrats all
being dead
it's just like all right okay I yeah
sure it's like I know it's [ __ ] now
but it's like it's still fun it makes
the star was more interesting yeah 100
also I love telling that to people in a
convincing voice being like yeah this is
real yeah this was actually what George
Lucas wanted yeah this is actually what
he wanted they wouldn't let him have it
yeah Disney's company
was gonna buy it yeah I think my
favorite hoax that has happened recently
was what happened with the Neo automata
Community oh that was a secret little
[ __ ] yep oh my God that was so five
hand on yokotara's like part him just
like playing along with it the thing the
thing I mean so if you don't know what
happened basically
um basically there was AR video posted
on the near subreddits of this new part
of Neo automata that had like never been
found before it was an Easter egg it
didn't even appear on them or anything
no mini map no nothing
um and it was from a user that
apparently like you know tried to post
this clip in the subreddit uh to find
out how to get out of this area what
this area was yeah and uh and there was
this entire like Odyssey of just this
user posting more and more areas of this
map that had just been uncovered and
this had like the new the near community
on like like he had them on the tip of
their balls you know he had their balls
yeah he had a vice grip on the [ __ ]
balls man
um and it was and the thing is it
wouldn't work for any other game right
because for any other game you'd be like
oh it's just a model it's just a prank
but Yoko Taro seems crazy enough to like
forget about something this big well
also yokotara actually made like a
statement being like Oh my God this is
an amazing secret I'm glad somebody
finally found it it was more vague he
was more like oh this is interesting I
wonder how that got yeah he may even
he'd been making like a really like yeah
and people like oh [ __ ] I should go into
the game and try and find it yeah
unfortunately it was a mod it was a new
mod community that you know had modded
the game even though the game couldn't
be more before that brief moment dude
near stocks just went like oh my God
yeah yeah that was it was so big brain
yeah I wasn't even like a big fan of
Nair but I was like like eating up
everything that was like going That's
what Nintendo needs to do like they need
to bring back the Lavender Town thing
like like
yeah yeah uh yeah I knew one of the kids
that like was awesome it was really
unfortunate and I actually owned the
original coffee in a vault the Nintendo
headquarters somewhere yeah just
bringing back porygons
oh my God Jesus okay I'm trying to think
of like other copy passes like what they
have like back in the day there's none
that were like that reached like the
level like bandra do you have like a
favorite coffee possible from back in
the day it's not really a copy pop
faster right yeah yeah Creepypasta not
really I was never a huge Creepypasta
guy I like the video essays on it like
Ben Drowned was great like that was
super cool that was good because I felt
like Ben drown was actually just
interesting yeah it was just how they
made it was a good story yeah so not
this isn't a hoax but my favorite Theory
like fan theory around something is
Snowpiercer being in the Willy Wonka
Universe if you know that one
like the train yeah the Train movie yeah
yeah it's a really convention do you
want to explain yeah I'll do my best
it's super deep so a YouTuber made this
very good video that explains how snow
piercer is likely a sequel direct sequel
to Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
yeah and the conductor like the main guy
at the end if you all seen the movie
yeah yeah so the guy at the end uh
that's Charles that's Charlie Bucket so
his argument is it's set up in the same
way that the Chocolate Factory was you
know it's all self-sustaining food plays
a big part with like the Cockroach bars
and [ __ ] like that yeah and it's set up
in like the class system where you move
up just like in the Chocolate Factory
yeah and he breaks down like all the
parallels between the characters in Snow
piercer and Willy Wonka and then he also
explains how bong Joon ho the director
was a big Charlie in the Chocolate
Factory fan who in an interview at some
point said something about how Willy
Wonka had inspired him to make something
like snow piercer right so he connects
all of these threads that have no reason
to connect well but does a great job of
actually making me believe there's a
chance that this does have some
connection it's really good it's called
snow piercer uh it might be just snow
peers there's a sequel to Willy Wonka
okay I'll check it out it's cool it's
really well I have so much admiration
for people who can make fan theories
that work yeah that work like I just
want to imagine like their entire like
bedroom is just like the [ __ ] cork
board was like all the strings attacking
and [ __ ] like that just like trying to
figure out yeah actually I've always
wanted this because you know like the
Zelda Timeline right yeah the Zelda
Cannon timeline so then before Nintendo
released it like there were like so many
[ __ ] fan theories like you know
theorizing about how all the Zelda games
connect together and it was only after
like it was only like I think like five
ten years ago that did Nintendo actually
make it Cannon but I'm like there's no
way they [ __ ] plan this right no I
swear to God they must look at these
fans make a new game
one of the most like convincing fan
Theory and was like yeah let's go with
that yeah because because like I think
compared to all the fan theories the
only difference was in zeld Ocarina of
times there are like it diverges into
three timelines there's two times yeah
yeah I'm like this is way too [ __ ]
convenient I swear to God someone that
Nintendo was looking at these fan
theories and like they were like we can
make this a thing we can definitely make
this a problem well they probably looked
at all the fan theories and was just
like all right next game we need to just
completely just [ __ ] up the time so that
they can just start from scratch Maybe
a [ __ ] ton of movies right yeah I watch
a lot of movies I I also try to go to
the theater as much as possible it's
really fun in Japan it's nice dude okay
you love I don't know if you have this
in America before you talk about movies
when you go to the theater in Japan uh
you get your popcorn get your drink you
get the screen and it has like a drink
slot and it goes in the drink holder oh
that's cool it's a trade you like swing
it around dude we don't have that here
but I know when I had this I was like
this is like a game Japanese Ingenuity
man you can fit so much stuff and I
don't have to carry it okay uh what do
you think is like one of the best moves
you've watched in like recent memory
oh it's tough yeah what would you say it
is yeah it's tough as well because I
don't I get I get it in Japan so the
release schedule is [ __ ] like some
movies come out the same time some come
out like eight months later I don't even
realize that's true
um or if it's detective Pikachu we got
it first for some reason oh yeah we yeah
yeah wow [ __ ] recent memory what's a
really good movie I want I can tell you
the best worst movie I've ever seen it
came out this year it's called moonfall
anyone seen moon no no it's a it's a
disaster movie where the moon
mysteriously gets out of orbit and it's
gonna crash into Earth you went to the
theaters also yep it is without a doubt
the best experience I've ever had it is
a two and a half hour ride two and a
half hours and it feels like 20 minutes
I was I was upset it wasn't longer it
was so impressively bad in every aspect
you could imagine but in all of the
right ways it was magic what was it just
like what made it like bad I I just like
the action legitimately everything about
that movie was bad but really
beautifully bad right right like
I don't want to spoil it but everything
happens I'm not gonna watch it you
should watch it I can't really you
should absolutely watch it that's like
my favorite type of video no yeah right
what's your favorite bad movie then
like the classics like the room and
stuff like yeah room obviously
um oh man like trolls too yeah what
about uh the brain what's it now brain
Neil Breen Neil Breen I'm here now
Double Down twisted pair you know them
old oh my God I'm a bad movie sommelier
all of the turbo shitty movies
yeah and moonfall is the best bad movie
wow okay and that came out this year
came out this year is it still in
theaters or is it no it's on Prime now
so I can't remember the guy's name like
the main character like he's a big actor
but the guy from Game of Thrones that
plays Sam is in it right yeah yeah
Samwell Tully yeah he's in it and it's
directed by Roland Emerich who does like
day after tomorrow 2012.
you know he made a new one and he was so
proud he said that he because this movie
flopped yeah I can't imagine why but it
didn't do well shockingly and he was so
salty he's like it's because of those
[ __ ] Marvel movies no one knows how
to make a good movie anymore like Moon
fall oh my god oh it's so good oh I
think out of all the films I've watched
this year in the theater I want to say
60 or 50 I didn't really enjoy that much
yeah that's why I was kind of like yeah
you know it's fine them a Marvel movie a
lot of the Marvel ones I watched this
year I thought were like okay yeah that
was a Marvel movie I did it Top Gun was
surprisingly good Top Gun was good
that's probably the best one I watched
this year I can't think what else came
out everywhere oh I think everywhere
unfortunately didn't come out in cinemas
in Japan
yeah I watched online
um I'm trying to think what else came
out this year the Batman come out this
year I really like the Batman these guys
didn't really like it that much do you
write the Batman yeah I thought it was
good I thought it was very good yeah I
like I like I'm obsessed with um Robin
pets good time no I haven't watched the
White House either yet good time is one
of my favorite films never watch it it's
if you watched um uncut gems yes it's
great it's uncut Jam so with Robert
Pattinson and even more anxiety oh
perfect so it's how old is so good uh
2017. yeah yeah you should watch it it's
really good it's he is when he was doing
this binge of like weird films that yeah
yeah he was doing it was it was like I'm
not that Twilight guy anymore you know
was not very good Swiss army man though
oh amazing film
and I've never seen that is that is it
as weird as it looks from like the
trailers and [ __ ] yeah yeah okay it's
[ __ ] weird but it's so good I can't
explain like just something about a
perpetually farting dead body of Daniel
Radcliffe is the funniest thing in the
world and it's like done in like and
it's told in like kind of a serious tone
right and it's just like it's amazing I
thought I thought I thought it was gonna
hate it he's made his bank oh yeah he's
just chilling
I'll do whatever I want isn't he just
doing a lot of Theater now yeah there's
a lot of theaters musicals yeah
yeah good on him okay what is the
worst anime you've watched as of late so
I've been on this I started this a
couple months ago I wanted to watch
every shitty anime ever made to find the
definitive worst one yeah so I mean I
did helter Heaven helter Skelton thank
you yeah to watch Muslim destruction
yeah
[Music]
I haven't gotten there yet that one's oh
my God yeah I think you'd love gazi
swing in dub like okay in Dub you're
gonna watch it yeah a lot of the shows
are shittier in dub yeah I watched the
abunai sisters
holy funny thing about guys doing you
know who made it no the creator of
Gundam really I'm 100 serious yeah wow
and it's [ __ ] amazing huh I don't
know what was he on I don't know
honestly watch guys this week it's only
three episodes you're it's it's like to
me it's the room of anime you know 100
it's like so bad that it's good so
what's what's the worst one you've seen
all right so far I'm on X arm and I've
been on X arm for over a month and a
half it's so [ __ ] bad it's like I'm
determined to finish all these awful
anime yeah when the trailer came out
everyone was like what it's watching it
is even worse it's so bad it's like a
kid playing with action I couldn't get
past like episode two I'm on episode
three and it's miserable
why are you doing this to yourself I
just want to find the worst one like I
gotta know you can't finish it yeah
right now it's X arm so right now the
worst one I've seen is X arms exam is
that it's not so bad and it's good it's
just bad it's just [ __ ] it's just bad
it's boring yeah which is a shame
because like I've read them longer and
it's actually not bad yeah it's just the
anime adaptation I don't know what the
[ __ ] happened they just I looked it up
so hard I looked it up they hired a guy
who had never like the director had
never done animation they hired like
someone who does real movies and like
action movies yeah and assumed he could
make it work in animation right and he
couldn't
yeah yeah
Jesus Christ it's just for me the part
that kills me with XOM is just like
right from the first episode is the fact
that like the main character is 3D well
everyone else was terribly good it's the
most I haven't watched it oh my gosh I'm
not gonna like it it is the most jarring
thing to watch it's so bad it's crazy
take some screenshots and these two
characters are oh yeah different
dimensions
why why is that is there a reason or is
it just lazy they had two they had
multiple Studios doing it so one of them
that didn't x-arm I think also did Elden
ring like uh they did some of the art
for Elden ring what really
like the studio was good I think it was
Elden ring I looked it up it has an
interesting story actually and how it
ended up being such a disaster
just gave it to the intro
I think it was just it was just a
perfect storm where it's probably yeah
nobody knew what they were working on
they just kept getting different and
conflicting directions from the upper
level yeah and I think like because I
think it was it a Crunchyroll original
yep
I remember when the ads started rolling
too crunchworld made sure to tell you it
was a crunch roll that's odd like why
did they not see it and just think yeah
we should maybe not advertise this much
that's what I always find most
interesting because you push it you know
it's bad like there's no one there that
knows it's there thinks it's good maybe
it's just like deals like priority it's
got to be just yeah yeah because no no
way would you be like yeah let's yeah I
think it's good to go yeah
promoting okay yeah let's do it like I
would hate to be in that boardroom where
they get the first trainer like I'm
gonna air this yeah they probably looked
down there was just like oh yeah so it
looks really good um I assume you're
going to do the finishing touches
it's a great scrolling storyboards guys
oh my God this episode of trash taste is
sponsored by Zen Market guys look at all
the stuff we got from Japan some of them
aren't even available if you live
outside Japan but don't you want to get
your hands on them yeah well with Zen
Market they can do exactly that for you
and because the Yen's drop in value
right now it is the perfect time to shop
for expensive Japanese items it's only a
300 Yen service fee which is barely
above two dollars probably one by the
time this airs and guys you get free
parcel consolidation you can combine
multiple items from different stores
into just one parcel with multiple
payment and shipping methods zenmarket
has 1.5 million customers worldwide and
they have a new store rocoma or Rock
dance flea market where you can find
rare and cheap items from all across
Japan so sign up now and you'll get your
first item with zero service fee so
smash that link in the description down
below back to the episode you asked
earlier off off camera you're like what
are what are our worst anime takes
what's got to be the hottest take they
got the community [ __ ] up in arms and
mad I in recent memory if you watched 86
yeah I actually like the 86 I I haven't
finished it but I've been trying I
thought it was so [ __ ] boring and I
said that on the podcast people lost it
they were like what do you mean I just
thought it was so slow that it was
preachy and I was like I don't care I'm
I'm just over it since it's been judging
me yeah I don't mind people who like
things I don't like I just like things I
do like I handle it like an adult if
only everyone in the anime yeah right
right I didn't think you think that was
a big hot take though people got really
I remember people were really annoyed
yeah uh you know juicy Kaizen yeah I
thought it was mid as [ __ ] see this is
one of those times where I can't be an
adult that's [ __ ] bad
that is just like all wrong that's just
a wrong opinion yeah
oh it's good yeah like it's like how can
you watch my hero Academia and then look
at Jiu Jitsu guys and be like that's
okay dude I didn't even get past season
one of Myers because it's so bad
Seasons yeah I caught up to watch season
six no same here why because apparently
this season's gonna be really good yep
according to Margaritas they've been
saying that every season yeah every
season and I'm like bet okay Margaritas
this is your last chance if season six
isn't good I'm gonna [ __ ] drop it I
swear to God is it good I haven't I
haven't said she was season five good
I've been on tour I've been on tour mate
season five is terrible season five is
the worst season this is so funny I just
I wasn't I remember Conor and I one day
we were just like wait there's six
seasons of this year I thought it was
still like season four yeah I literally
I think I've watched I don't know when
it was one when they had like the
gentleman and the little [ __ ] that's
the gentle criminal that's season five
yeah that's I I watched up to five yep
that's season five I got there whenever
they introduced them and I'm like what
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] it's so bad it's
so bad I was like oh we just derailed
the whole plot to have some kind of like
scooby-doo-esque side plot the whole
show is like nothing but the worst parts
of anime where they focus on like
provisional exams for licensing boring
and it's like it's crazy because like
what like three four years ago this show
was the [ __ ] yep it was I remember when
season two was a very good especially
like during the tournament Arc oh my God
it was inescapable dude every single
anime convention was everyone's
cosplaying my hair yeah yeah you
couldn't escape it and then it just fell
off a cliff season three yeah no one
spoke about it fumbled so hard because
they had like this big building like Yo
dude it shouldn't be so deep and then he
he like went halfway through the season
and was like wait what yeah I guess like
my hot take that I haven't said I guess
publicly and this was this is actually
exclusive this was actually before
cyberpunk the cyberpunk anime yeah okay
but I was like I kind of think oh I kind
of think trigger is a bit overrated okay
it's just yeah yeah this was before
cyberpunk by the way before so now how
do you feel about it yeah
[ __ ] amazing amazing but it felt like
before cyberpunk it just kind of felt
like they just kind of they they knew
how they they had like really really
good branding but it felt like so long
since they released like an absolute
bang I I kind of get what you mean it
was good I thought DNA was so average
BNA is what I felt like it was like a
their practice for cyberpunk yeah in a
weird way did you watch DNA no I
actually didn't watch BNA I because they
like did not promote it I feel that I've
heard of it yeah I thought it was I
thought it was decent it wasn't like
amazing yeah that's the thing with most
trigger shows the only trigger shows I
really liked was kill the kill and uh I
love darling in the frame
grid man grid man you don't like
premiere I thought you think I think it
was decent but I think it was just I I
think it's just like recycling the same
formula although that's the thing right
I feel I feel trigger is able to get
away with a lot of [ __ ] that I think
other Studios would not be able to get
away with because of their branding
right yeah it's just like you see
something ridiculous happen in a trigger
show yeah and you know if it was any
other Studio then people would be like
what the [ __ ] is this like why why
derail yourself but if it's triggers
doing it then it's like that's just
trigger being triggered if if [ __ ]
Studio bones or you photo will release
Inferno cop everyone will like [ __ ]
throw hands wow I swear to God
absolutely yeah because uh to those of
them watching Punk please go watch it
yeah um there's uh you know because
obviously it's trigger there's like a
lolly character in it and did you see
this interview that they had with one of
the it's like it was one of the cdpr
people right and they were doing a
podcast where they were they were
interviewed about something like Rebecca
yeah about Rebecca yeah and apparently
when they first pitched the idea of
Rebecca this is uh you know project read
the light what we don't want a lolly
there's no lollies in cyberpunk what is
this can you remove it the family tree
was like no the Lolly stays we don't do
the show
I'm just like like you could you imagine
this like awkward-ass like 12 meeting
people with like translators and
everything and they say hey we just can
we remove the lolly in the like memory
yeah they say it back and then they're
just like the Lolly stays
all right okay weird all right but I
almost think that like yeah like you
said trigger was kind of I felt like the
shows weren't that good and I I almost
wonder if maybe because they had to
collaborate a bit and kind of had to
work with uh maybe some outside uh
influence that maybe it kind of you know
maybe a bit of restriction sometimes
make a better product no I I really
that's why I think cyberpunk was so good
it's good like well I think working with
CD projekt Red they've really like
reeled them in so they had something
more creative yeah so I was like yo what
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] now get rid of
that no you the girls cannot be wearing
no clothes at all come on yeah because I
think I think seeing them really
experiment with like the you know hyper
violence and the gore was just like so
[ __ ] good and so I mean it was like a
throwback to like the old like
production IG [ __ ] right yeah right
because like I I feel like when trigger
became triggered that's when they kind
of like tone down on like the adult
things and stuff like obviously I've
been killed a kill right yeah because
like after killer kill everyone was if
anything was kind of like okay yeah this
is like it's pretty toned down it was
all right I didn't think it was like
Gray movie yeah I'm curiously wanted to
give uh Sarah Punk on your moisture
meter I give it a 90.
yeah the first opening if you haven't
watched it the first opening scene is so
goddamn good oh yeah yeah and like the
moment that first scene played I was
like oh [ __ ] this is going to be
something [ __ ] special it was it was
episode oh that was good as well episode
six is a master it might be one of my
favorite episodes of anime ever it's so
good have you ever seen the new chainsaw
man anime yeah yep I watched episode one
it was good it was good what do you
think of the did you come in Japan it
was like come in your pants good though
it was very good there was no no soiled
trousers but it was good this is what I
said yeah right it's it's a first
episode yeah like it did what it needs
to do I don't think everyone made it
seem like it was the second coming of
Jesus Christ came down to bless us with
some
anime waifus and chainsaws and it was
just like all right you know they hyped
with all the animation and the budget
and whatever the phone or whatever they
want to call it yeah I shouldn't say
budget I got in trouble last time I said
that oh that was that was that was a
that was an anime
did you ever see that no when I said
that you know Demon Slayer
um I've grown tangent now when I the
Demon Slayer last season came out and
and the last fight was insane did you
see it like the animation was just yeah
I tweeted out being like dude this
budget is nuts and then it unraveled
into this whole thing where like a
certain few people were like yo what the
[ __ ] you you can't call it budget it's
it's not about the budget it's about the
individual animators that work on it is
spreading this information and then I
didn't say anything and I just kind of
left you I was like oh whatever
yeah and then like uh apparently
somebody one of the guys he was tweeting
about it some people tweeted back at him
being like yo is it this is a joke chill
out yeah and apparently it all unraveled
and they claimed they got swatted and
stuff and it over you just saying the
budget yeah the next day I work out
people were like this is unacceptable he
needs to address this I'm like I just
said that they had a budget okay what
the [ __ ] happened I was just like what
what that was just so surreal it was so
bizarre I had to make a trip how to make
a twit longer being like hey guys uh it
was a joke uh please don't forget crazy
it's anime can we all chill the [ __ ] out
all right you're lucky that those are
just the anime fans could you imagine if
Demon Slayer was a live-action TV series
but it was just so like what like you
look at it and you're like this is the
most Twitter moment ever yeah
like certain groups they work each other
up and then they're just out for blood
and they get a little bit and they're
like yo this is it this is it
yeah and it's like okay there was an
agenda here and it was just like weird
you know I was like I don't know what I
did or what happened and this is weird I
don't know yeah Twitter's assessment
yeah but you got to be on it right like
you have no choice I'm always on it just
because that's how I get like all the
updates to [ __ ] and find things it's
like it's just such a quick source of
information I mean if you want to stay
up to date with like drama or Internet
news yeah oh yeah you got to be on
Twitter yeah absolutely God remember the
times where you saw a twit longer and
you didn't assume someone was getting
like canceled or apologizing holy [ __ ]
this is a long explanation yeah
one thing I'm curious about as a as your
creator has been on the platform so long
because obviously sometimes you you do
cover drama how is it sometimes let's
say if like drama happens with someone
that maybe you have connections to or
maybe you're like close ties to or maybe
even you know maybe sometimes you're
like am I is this okay if I talk about
this like it's you know like how do you
how do you handle that thing that I've
always I've always like stayed away from
ever talking about [ __ ] publicly about
any even if there's drama happening I
think all three of us yeah yeah because
I'm just like I'm like what if this like
somehow like they bounce back and they
remember me being an [ __ ] and I'm the
piece of [ __ ] who said something even
though it was totally you know what I
mean I'm like always like I don't know
how do you like how do you deal with
that I don't know it's all impulsive
like I don't really give a lot of
thought like if it's like some goofy
drama I'll usually just be like this is
why it's goofy this is Goofy this is
what they're doing and this is what
happened yeah I never really think like
if there's any like angle that could
have been worked right or something like
that I also feel like with the way you
address a lot of that kind of stuff in
your videos you're very articulate with
it first of all but I feel you're
addictions
very articulate but like I feel in a lot
of ways you're also you I don't know if
you're trying to consciously do this but
I feel in a lot of ways you're very like
neutral and fair about the situation
like you kind of just like say it how it
is and like these are the facts this is
what's happening here's like my tiny
little two cents and then that's it kind
of thing right you don't really like you
know pick a side blatantly usually
unless it's something that I like have a
very strong opinion of right like yeah
for example like the pink sauce lady she
was on top
if you were on the other side then I
think everyone would have been like what
the [ __ ] yeah like there are times where
I'll pick a side like yeah of course
this from reading or learning about all
this but you didn't know the pink Source
lady poses
[Music]
but I feel if it's with Like You Know
Drama concerning like a fellow content
creator for example oh like someone I
know yeah like someone you know I feel
you're very good at kind of being
neutral about it yeah I mean [ __ ]
twitch every week
pretty much I'll be out of forensics
yeah yeah there's not a whole lot left
everyone's always getting tossed into
something yeah is there even any point
covering it is it like this is not new
only if it's I usually only cover it if
it's entertaining or if it's something
that I'm like feeling strongly about
like it's like a serious situation yeah
I have a pretty strong opinion on what's
going on here I'll cover it but then
other times where if it's like
without getting like too specific like
someone going through like a mental
health episode yeah broadcasting it I'm
not gonna talk about that yeah but I
feel what's good is that you have like
such a big variety of content that you
don't need to like pressure yourself oh
yeah to make content about drama or
stuff like that yeah yeah because I mean
I mean there are like so many like
commentary drama channels and YouTube
now like I swear people there's like
entire channels which is the genre is
let's like take this one tweet and like
make a [ __ ] video about it you know
well I've definitely done that I've seen
some dog [ __ ]
I couldn't help it was it a chef Rogan
won that one time oh that was that one
what was that one the one was like why
are you complaining about your car being
broken yeah it was it opens all the time
Casey neistat made a tweet he's like a
[ __ ] car got broken into ages I hate
L.A Seth Rogen replied to it he's like
why are you why are you upset LA's one
of the best cities on Earth you just
have to know if you park your car
outside you're going to get broken into
my car is broken into 15 times they even
left me a treat one time so he's like
he's like and he was fully serious he
was 100 serious it was the worst [ __ ]
tweet I've ever read I love that truth
out of touch celebrity Twitter oh my God
oh my gosh actually one question I've
always wanted to ask you is uh
concerning YouTube right so your lack of
thumbnails is that like is that by
choice yeah and I just don't give it a
lot of thought and I don't stretch them
on purpose for what it's worth yeah
some of the ones I see and I'm like that
has to be like a Photoshop edit no it's
never so I I use Sony Vegas any Sony
Vegas oh yeah yeah you see you see that
we're terrible we are terrible we are
inferior
listen this is why I don't edit my
videos it's like Sony Vegas I don't know
how to end so in Sony Vegas you'll know
when you put in an image sometimes it
gets those black bars on the side you
just stretch
I click stretch it and then the
screenshot I click uh I untick maintain
aspect ratio it stretches it for me and
then I save the screenshot
ten percent more effort than prosies
he told us that he just picks one of the
three I used to do that I used to but
yeah I stopped because now for some
reason YouTube's really fixated on those
Auto generated thumbnails on the goofy
[ __ ] like when my eyes are closed it's
like he's like yeah [ __ ] it I'll do it
no he's got
he's great yeah he's awesome yeah I love
the whole low after thumbnail thing I
love it so much it's really cool I just
shot doing that important in Sony Vegas
yeah I would say just untick maintain
aspect ratio you'll see the light you'll
be like wow
okay so what are you putting in that the
video or like a screenshot so I'll just
take like a screenshot of the video but
it takes those black bars on the side so
yeah bring it in and
untick the end why can't you just open
up the video in like VLC and just
screenshot makes no sense no you're
speaking he doesn't even know Sunny
Vegas works
even if it's a [ __ ] like vertical
phone video you just like [ __ ] blow
yeah
like [ __ ] yeah we're gonna look at your
Channel right now could you imagine a
frizzy did that [ __ ] all of these videos
are just like
this is awful some of them are so
stretched what is this DJ Khaled almost
died
you didn't even get it yeah that one was
on when I unclicked maintain aspects
Sony bag was like I can't bro bro I
couldn't even I can't do this one that
one was a little too much even the power
of Vegas couldn't make way do you okay I
I know obviously this is do you make all
your thumbs up make is a strong word do
you make it
almost all of them if it's a bigger
project like God slap or something yeah
like podcast
damn and you edit your Nvidia still
sometimes all of them that aren't like
the bigger projects yeah so just the
ones of you in your room talking about
something damn it's really not much work
the fact that you can just commit to
that and do it yeah and the fact that
you upload 60 videos a month if it was
like once a week then I'd be like yeah
okay not much extra effort right but
you're doing it like almost every day
and it's pretty quick though you just
it's like what you guys do with the you
know podcast you just talk just talk at
a camera and then like the editing is
pretty simply just cut like you just put
the things together
for me that's what I do like if it's
just talking I just splice it and then I
mean if you ask me to edit this podcast
I'll be like [ __ ] that well I guess it's
harder because you have to sync
everyone's audio and everything right
yeah whenever you say anything he throws
it off yeah awful and we have like the
whole time stamps and everything he does
that it is a beast yeah it's a lot
absolute machine thank you very much
episode 100 will be thanked me down for
keeping this podcast
I'm glad you still use Sony Vegas I'm
one of the still I'm few people I know a
few YouTubers who still use Sony Vegas
there's four of us now it's the three of
us and then TUV TUV makes a lot of like
dark content like surrounding like you
know twitch moments or stalkers and
stuff like that we have four Sony Vegas
users
I feel the Fisher Price of editing songs
yeah it is okay it legitimately is like
it is it is designed for literal like 10
years it's like none of the stuff makes
sense professionally but if you're
literally doing the bare minimum it's
the easiest do you want to be a YouTuber
you must face the Elite Four yeah yeah
when you're starting out it is really
easy to get it it's so easy I feel so
bad because I do actually like higher
edited sometimes right and obviously
they use [ __ ] like Premiere Pro yes
because they're relatives and I feel bad
because I still have like a hand in the
editing process so what I'll do is I'll
get them to render out the video and
render out the audio separately and then
I re-edited so many people
it simply isn't it can be fun if you
have like an actual good editing project
well like if it's I'd say if it's not
you directly like if you're editing your
own thing I feel like it's just oh [ __ ]
it's just not fashion oh yeah it's just
I do it it's done yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's quick it's easy yeah I definitely
see like it being fun for like a bigger
project if you've got like some project
that you're like have a hand in yeah
it's much better yeah yeah what I like
is like having like big fun projects and
I get my editing team to do like the
bulk of the work I do like the fun
little bits I enjoy the creative
expression yeah yeah something like that
exactly
yeah right right yeah the moment I could
have I I was able to afford an editor I
was like I'll go broke I do not want to
do this it's just not fun I would it
would make videos that should have been
like two days like two weeks because I
would just procrastinate I'd be like
I'll play another game of League I did I
did one like chroma key or one key frame
that's it that's the day awful stuff
what games are you into now
it's a lot better so they took out a
player so it's 5v5 yeah one less tank
yeah and that changed everything so the
game's like actually fun now can they
come back after all the controversy they
had I don't I don't think it'll ever be
an esport again like I think the Esports
scene I think is [ __ ] like there's
really I don't think there's much they
can do this appeal to the porn Community
I think that's the way it's huge the
porn Community is massive I feel like if
they just cater towards that just keep
giving them characters they can make
porn off I think it'll say around I
think that's the problem they started
making robots and [ __ ] and it was not
doing it for like that's when near
automatic dinner right yeah yeah I mean
some of the most talented 3D artists and
animates I know are all doing [ __ ]
porn
it's insane how good it looks man
Widowmaker and diva porn was like better
than anything pixel ever put out like it
was shocking everything from that
Community is on another level
is it's like the Pentagon comes together
to like bring all their processing power
to make 20 second Loop of Widowmaker
getting wrapped it's insane and let's
not forget Tifa is now officially part
of Italian law yeah right yeah
legendary that's so good just one of my
favorite meme videos I saw recently was
just like the history of it of Italy and
it's just like the entire like a quick
like uh PNG of like the entire history
of Italy then there's one frame of tea
for us here
it's probably Italy they had like a
prime minister like I don't know like
two prime ministers ago that would
openly talk about having orgies and
stuff was that Italy I know who you're
talking about I don't think you were
talking about having orgies all the time
he's like 70. [ __ ] he was insane dude he
I don't know why Italians loved him like
he would talk about orgies and they'd be
like yeah dude what an alpha male I'm
[ __ ] voting for that guy he was in
this guy is insane like you hear him
talking like this is this is not someone
who should be running this guy should be
managing at Danny's at best like this is
this is not prime minister material
Italian Hugh Hefner running the [ __ ]
phone because that's what that's the top
of Italian priority like [ __ ] like
everything else is second like maybe
like pasta or something yeah
the economy
third no no not even dude not even what
is the best state in the
oh that's Florida great great stage did
you travel that much Taylor not at all
you said really uh I think uh before the
show you said you've been to like Texas
and stuff right yeah Texas is nice I
really like Texas Texas is like a
Florida with better weather is that the
photos no I've been out of the country
once I went to Canada when I was a kid
it's not like a store I mean I guess
it's a cool story I went skiing on the
same Hill that Liam Neeson's wife died
on
but I went there like a year before it
happened oh right it's not a cool story
I guess yeah
and then they won't let you back into
Canada they did now I can't go back yeah
yeah I mean do you ever talk about
because obviously I think it's well
known that you've like a fear of flying
yeah did you talk about that much no
only when it comes up I just don't fly
how did that like fear develop I guess
how did it all start yeah I don't know
when Matt started but the other day I
told the the group here I'm also like a
legitimate hypochondriac and I know
exactly where that started my doctor
before I went to high school made a big
song and dance out of the meningitis
shot because you needed it to go to the
high school okay and I was like up until
this point I was pretty Carefree I could
like eat worms I'd jump in lakes and
then my doctor when he was told to give
me the meningitis shot he's like I'm not
doing that it's gonna paralyze your son
like your son's gonna die from this is
like a crazy doctor he was fine all the
way up until this point he told me he
said that in front of me and I was like
what does he mean mom he's gonna is this
gonna kill me and so I went home and I'm
like Googling these things yeah it was
horrifying I Googled all these things
about like the side effect like Gillian
Parr syndrome or something where I guess
is what he was talking about was he like
some kind of like conspiracy he must
have been and then from that point
forward I was afraid of everything I
still got the shot but I was afraid to
[ __ ] traumatized yeah he legitimately
gave me hypochondria for life to be fair
if a doctor tells you yeah at a young
age how old are you in that it was right
before high school I would have been
going on that would have scared though
yeah I hadn't thought about that for
years until the other day I brought it
up to the team I was like that's
absolutely where that started damn
that's totally understandable I don't
know where the plane stuff started
though I remember watching Phoenix uh
Flight of the Phoenix when I was a kid
where the plane crashes in the desert
and they kill each other yeah [ __ ]
that's a sick irony
yeah because I mean like you know you
obviously love so much like you know
Japanese like you know media and content
stuff like that like I'm sure there's
somewhere in your head where you're like
I really [ __ ] want to know suck it
off and go to Japan right
down this is such a long flight 12 hours
I'd be like an anesthesiologist to keep
me
what I'm hearing is if there's somewhere
that you can get there being drunk I
think it'd be great like I think it'd be
a really fun trip
you'd have a field day with all the [ __ ]
you can find them oh my God it is an
absolute content gold mine yeah
especially for you like you'd find so
much weird [ __ ] we've all been talking
about it too like we've all wanted to
make that trip it's just for me it's
[ __ ] hard yeah yeah if it's like a
fear it's a fear right yeah it's not not
sure someone would be like yeah
obviously I know it's not gonna crash
but it's like I don't think that I think
it's I I hate it I don't want to be up
there you know yeah I mean it doesn't
matter how many like you know little
information tidbits of like oh if you
didn't die in the car crash on the way
to the airport and you've survived again
so tired don't be scared Charlie come on
oh my God you're putting yourself in
danger more every single day in a car
than you are on a plane and it's like
okay yeah easier said than done yeah
yeah cause a lot of people would ask us
all the time like what are you gonna get
Charlie I'm like well you know we have a
very strict policy and it has to be in
person yeah people just wouldn't shut
the [ __ ] up about it yeah and we're like
so we have to make our way
Charlie he made us come all the way to
Tampa Florida
it's awesome being here but no I mean
like it's yeah it's a lot
you know and it's it's like you couldn't
you couldn't be further from Japan I'm
just praying for like another Pangea
where everything comes
I just don't want to be close to Florida
are you kidding me no you make the drive
across yeah I'll drive across even it's
like a five-day drive I'm on land
Florida just breaks off from the rest of
America and floats its way towards Asia
so do you ever think like do you ever
get like a bit Shady like [ __ ] I'll
probably never like see Europe yeah like
I do think about that I'm not like a big
outdoorsy guy like yeah seeing sites is
cool but it's not something like top of
mind all right but with Japan in
particular it's like so many things that
I know are like exclusive to there that
I won't be able to do if I don't go yeah
so that one's like actually tough that
in Sweden Sweden seems like another
really cool spot why Sweden like dream
hack and everything everything oh yeah
yeah like it just seemed like a really
cool spot with a lot of stuff to do yeah
that makes sense where's the furthest
you have traveled in is it Canada just
Canada okay yeah it was nice yeah
you drove there actually no I actually
flew oh it's my four years ago yeah no
like I was scared then too but like I
have sucked it up and flown I flew to
Dallas like two months ago now but it's
it's just really it's a lot yeah yeah I
know there's a few friends of mine where
it's like um
they have to like they will fly but it's
like they have to do like 50 things
before just to like calm themselves if
they don't do all of those things they
won't get on the plane Jesus and it'll
be like weird things it'll be like you
know you have to wear the right pair of
socks because that's what they've
convinced themselves right like that's
that's and it's obviously they they and
it's not like they've done they know
that it's irrational and they know that
it doesn't make sense they just can't do
anything in your mind it's just like you
just you you think that like you have to
do this and if you don't do it you're
not comfortable yeah and even then
getting on the plane is terrifying or
like doing the certain thing or going
going to the doctors getting the shot
it's like it's different for everyone
our minds are [ __ ] weird yeah yeah
they do not work well I'm not anti-backs
by the way
I get all my shots just fine it's just
hypochondria with germs and meningitis
in my University someone died she's from
meningitis really yeah because I didn't
get the shot oh [ __ ] and I was like oh
I'm glad I took this because they tell
you it's oh it's super serious and
you're like I never [ __ ] head of this
disease yeah why is no one talking about
it someone at my University got measles
yeah
we had a guy get measles I think it's
gonna see a big uptick it's coming it's
coming back unfortunately measles is on
the camera oh man those stocks are up
it's it's it's sad yeah it is
you're going to be seeing the bibronic
plague I think we'll be fine down here
though like we we're tough
we'll be fine Linda you're like the New
York rats right like I said like you
develop so well but it's like oh god
what happened like you're like it's like
impossible to get rid of you you're like
what have we created like cockroaches
like just surviving yeah
bro British people could not survive
hurricanes and [ __ ] like that and floods
no but we're done we're done with the
sun is out like we're like [ __ ] you guys
have like Darkness for most of the time
right like it's always rainy rainy and
cloudy it's mostly grow actually I've
realized this the other day
um when I was back in England and it was
raining I was depressed and I realized I
like that you you love that but I
realized only in England do I find rain
really depressing in a lot of other
places I kind of like dig it it kind of
like it's kind of like a Vibe sometimes
it fits in Japan I kind of like I kind
of like the rain in Japan but that's
because everything in Japan is aesthetic
that's that's true that's true well I
should ask why all the Lo-Fi goes with
it man yeah exactly looking around if
you're in Tokyo and it starts raining
you just put some Lo-Fi on and you
that's a Vibe now yeah you can't do that
in England yeah you'll have a clear
umbrella as well the clear umbrella so
you can see the rain dudes yeah
that's the jam right there oh my God
have you ever tried learning another
language I'm curious I tried learning
Japanese I took an entire semester in
college really yep it didn't go super
well not every language guy yeah it was
tough we suck it
we suck right now I can only remember a
few things I tried they taught us kanji
I can't do that they treat taught you
kanji yep they touched
they did all three in that semester they
tried to teach us like a little bit I
feel like it's pointless yeah that's why
I don't remember any but it was just
like too much the only thing I remember
is how to say like what is your
telephone number which is I think it's
ano TOA didn't understand
that's the only thing that stuck with me
in that entire semester you'll learn all
these kanji and then like 80 percent of
the kanji you see a bridge and Mountain
yeah like a lot of the time pretty much
obviously there's way more but 90 like
so many of them are bridging Mountain I
think it's it's just Yama it was a lot
yeah I I just don't see how effective
that could be in trying to learn all of
that in one semester no no I mean you'd
have you probably have a better time
just like you know watching anime
probably yeah I feel like I've got more
out of that like I know yeah
as well yeah hentai's good Bible black
taught me a lot the school of Bible the
only Bible I read have you ever seen the
dub of Bible blacks I love it
I only watched the double Bible black
recently like maybe like a couple years
ago yeah and I'm so upset at myself that
it took me this long to watch it a lot
of the really shitty hentai dubs I've
watched a few of them I've watched Bible
black and then I've watched that one
where the professor I don't remember
exactly like [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm squeezing on your Supple breasts
janitors Club
there's like a medieval one where like
there's a woman with like f-sized tits
It's so funny and she's like I'm sorry I
killed your granddad by suffocating with
my tits and it's just like she delivers
it straight and the whole dialogue is
like it's so funny
it's an entire like gold mine of just
hence nine percent of them they they
turn it into like a from a hentai to a
comedy oh yeah it's much better than the
shitty anime
yeah way more entertaining as well in my
opinion I mean yeah because it's
basically just like porn acting right
like it's it's hilarious it's supposed
to be serious but it's hilarious yeah I
guess because it's like they they took
this Japanese script and they're like oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah just make it better
yeah yeah I think a lot of the time the
the licensing deals and those are like
not as strict as the others at least
back then they were straight man yeah I
guess they still dab hentai sometimes
yeah I haven't heard like a modern dub
hint I get the casting call center times
really yeah have you taken them no
appreciate those yeah I am never the
main I am never the character you're
never think about the guys my voice just
doesn't I I'm not the like the nerdy kid
with the head and I'm not the ugly
person you should do it I am not doing
anything you should you should do it
dude yeah yeah do it if I had that
classical
I can't do this one but I know a guy who
might be you can play the ugliest basket
no I know you'd like it because the
moment you it comes out you're like I've
been in Civilization
you're a fattest cheek anime
that would be on your bio yeah let's go
on the iron ugliest bastard in hentai
because I remember like a lot of like OG
voice actors used to use pseudonyms uh
doing like hentai work so I remember
like I remember the Yu-Gi-Oh yummy Yugi
yeah and the guy who did uh Professor
Oak yeah they've both been in hentai and
they have such distinctive is it's
literally Professor Oak
which one is it I want to watch it
there's there's one about like this it's
this weird like four part uh because I
found it it's just [ __ ] weird it's
about like these um like shamans and
they're like
they're like taking these girls
kidnapping them then [ __ ] them but
then they have like a master roshi type
who's and it's just really weird and
they keep kidnapping these good it's so
bizarre Center to you yeah it's so weird
it's like it's exactly what you expect
of like a weird ass hentai yeah and
what's that one with the one where she's
like oh my tits are Torpedoes as well
that's like mother's milk or something
that's what it's called they all and I
asked this to the people who made them I
asked them why the English name should
the Japanese ones like the mid-2000s and
ten times were so like porn-esque yeah
and they were like well apparently it
just sold better like when they renamed
it to like when they gave them shitty
porn title names they sold so much
better than when they gave them literal
translations well yeah because they
probably looked at like a title like
mother's milk and was like I have to
[ __ ] watch this yeah like mother
knows breasts yeah like mother knows
breasts yeah like that was not the
original title like the Japanese titles
are like a love story between mother and
son yeah
I don't [ __ ] want to do this what do
you want about I don't want butter to
watch this but then I think the weirdest
thing I've seen that is just like you
know childhood ruin moment was it wasn't
a hentai but I remember there was uh
there was an AIDS advert right okay okay
where is this going and and in this Aid
campaign right to you know inform people
of our AIDS yeah
um yeah no no in America okay they hired
the voice actors of Shinji and Oscar
from from Evangelion what and so you
here in this and it is it's a it's like
a audio campaign right yeah and so
there's a scene in this campaign about
two people having sex and it's like it
is it is just Shinji and Oscar having
sex basically it's just it's just it's
just it's safe like ASMR oh my God it's
like I remember hearing that and I'm
like oh my God I can never look at it I
can never look at Ava the same again oh
my God all we should have I never heard
of that yeah the reporting's on YouTube
do you do a lot of voice acting you did
so for some games right I've done some
I'm not very good I love doing it but
I'm just pretty bad we both did
um what was that game where it was like
a table talk kind of like card yeah uh
card game the dungeon game yeah that
game is not good it's a good gameplay
um yeah I mean how good we are put on
the screen later yeah it was it was a
fun no because Munoz gonna message me
this is what happens we say put it on
the screen and then he messages me
asking what it was and I'm like I don't
know because I would have said it okay
look up Charlie's IMDb he's probably on
there yeah dude I I pulled my heart out
for that I did like four characters as
well I did so much work and I only did
one like no one played it no
I did lucious three though do you know
that game oh what is lucious that's like
that's not like uh you just kill people
as like a little devil child oh yeah I
voiced a character in there it is the
worst voice acting
life have I seen this thing I think I
might have seen this maybe it's it's not
that old it's only like three years what
does the character look like your voice
a nerd he looks very nerdy maybe I've
seen this yeah and is he just like
Charlie voice
in my defense they didn't give me like
direction for the character so I just
read it like I wouldn't I I really like
a voice critical video
when you see it in the game it's like it
doesn't seem right yeah it feels like I
did a dub of this character and they put
it in I can just imagine playing the
game and you get up to the nerd
character and be like hey loose you're
so really so much I really appreciate
that
it's just like Charlie's boys
[Laughter]
like when you're in something it's like
that's a character when when I'm in
those games it's like why is Charlie
that's what I do if I do the British
thing and people are like I just can't
unhair Connor because when if I ever do
like just my normal voice kind of more
British they're like oh it's you just
tone yeah
but it's like I'm pompous come here
that's that's what you got to do instead
of learning a new language you've got to
like figure out like new accents oh
different accent yeah like if you if you
do if you do like a role in like a
British accent there won't be a they'll
probably hear less of Charlie sure I
should have done that yeah probably is
that I like I cannot not sound like
myself yeah you two have that you two
have like very very interesting voices
and it's very hard to hear anything else
when you're changing your voice yeah I
mean I've never heard you change your
voice much I can't do it very well you
can only do Scooby-Doo saying one line
go on to it already
that's all I got
it I mean yeah it works
Scooby whenever he voice acts it just
sounds like him yeah it does it just I
go into like my YouTuber voice you know
not every voice actor needs to sound
different yeah it's a common
misconception you know there are a lot
of voice actors out there who um just
sound like the same character every time
but they're really good at acting and
really good at making oh you know like
sugimoto like you know he's like one of
the biggest Japanese voice actors he
sounds exactly the same in all of his
roles but people love that things yeah
Johnny Johnny
the protagonist voice yeah yeah Steve
Bloom just always sounds like Spike
Spiegel yeah that's awesome yeah I love
that he does hell yeah yeah sure dude oh
you know we actually another thing that
we both did
um what was that movie you were in the
last of the grads yeah yeah I was in
wait you were in last year I'm divorce
is the Killer
holy [ __ ] I had no idea that was your
voice that's awesome yeah and if you did
an American accent yeah it's an American
accent yeah they were like he's so I got
on the call with them because they think
I don't know how it all came about
um they asked me to do it and I was like
yeah sure because they were like oh
chocolate Center I was like Charlie's in
all right sure because you had like an
actual role in it it was officer Greg so
I was like oh [ __ ] sure why not how
how many lines can it be I was like sure
whatever and they were like so we need
to be the voice of the Killer and I was
like all right cook so I get on the call
then we're about to do it
and I'm like I stopped doing the lines
and they're like oh no no no he's
American and I was like oh kind of wish
you told me that like before because I
could like prep a little bit and I was
like so whereabouts in America is he
from thinking like I'm just stalling so
I'm like [ __ ] I need to think of like a
voice now and he's like ah from
Washington I'm like oh yeah yeah easy
yeah
I got that so she started this thing and
they're like yeah it works it was just
some kind of creepy voice I don't know
yeah I I but I think um I I think I
don't know if they fixed it or not I
think they like forgot to credit me
really they never I don't think in the
official credits of the IMDb I'm
credited at all damn
but then again I saw the review scores
and I'm like maybe yeah
officer Greg really put his best on the
line I saw another reviews for us like
this movie's shocked but I like seeing
Charlie
I it was it was a shame because when I
spoke to the guys they were really
passionate about it yeah they really
went forward they really put that on it
and it was a shame because you're like
damn is this one of those things where
like you have a vision but it's just not
quite realized yeah except for officer
Greg sometimes you just get it right did
you watch the whole movie yeah oh okay I
mean I haven't I don't know how I sound
in it I I didn't know it was you so you
sounded pretty good all right okay good
yeah because there was a there was an
actor who was actually playing the
character right but then but it wasn't
their voice he was wearing a mask so he
basically did like the Darth Vader so
yeah I was like it was kind of yeah yeah
exactly right it was kind of like that
so then I think he was unmatched at one
point yeah but I again I didn't have
much I I what do you got like burned
alive and I remember I ruined my throat
at having to do those lines right
because I did it like eight takes and
they were like can we have like one more
and I was like I only have one more this
isn't the tape we don't have anymore
oh God it's so bad oh no I don't know I
don't know if it's good maybe I should
watch it maybe I shouldn't I don't know
do you like watching like shows or like
movies that you voice in there's times
okay I there's certain voices in certain
voice types and certain character types
that I know that I can just like that my
voice learns really well to and that I I
tend to like if it's a cocky [ __ ] I'm
like okay I feel like I can do that
really well
those type of characters I feel like
really comfortable doing but when it's
more like stuff out of my range I don't
really like watching it because I'm like
man I feel like I just didn't do a good
job all right well you could do better
kind of like I feel like I know I could
do better and I probably should watch it
back so I could learn right um but also
also if it's something that I'm like
it's a it's a video game or an anime or
a TV show that I'm really passionate
about I'll I'll watch it
um like I hope yeah I think I think it's
out by by the time this comes out like
Omega Strikers I'm really [ __ ]
excited to hear what I sound like in
that game yeah because I don't know what
it's like I'm so [ __ ] hyped because
the game looks good I haven't even
played it because we don't still have to
play it yeah because you've been on tour
this whole time I haven't been able to
play it but all my friends at player say
it's so fun and it's addictive and I'm
like no finally a game that I've always
said that's good or like they're not
good but popular chart yeah yeah yeah so
I'm excited for that yeah damn yeah I'm
sorry tangent about me sorry
it was us last the grads
that's crazy so that's like one two or
three things now we've both like done
things for all right nice
time you've got to be in a movie
together yeah like live action where do
I watch last of grads when I can get it
I don't know if it's still on the same
site that it launched on I think it went
to a triller
okay is it shutter or trailer yeah the
only thing I know how that is that they
sued the H3 yeah I don't know if it's
truly which one's the horror one is it
shutter okay
yeah I know what the one you're talking
about yeah my wife watches a new horror
movie every day and it's always on this
side it's what everyone she's watching
yeah yeah yeah it's the one with all the
horror movies on yeah that process
really really really made me feel bad
for people who make movies that don't do
well oh my God yeah it's gotta be
miserable I was like because you know
like these these when we talked to them
about it they would I'm sure you had the
same thing like they were really
passionate you know on you know that I'm
sure they all are yeah it's like it's
like [ __ ] could you imagine putting so
much time and effort in something that
people are like it's jokes and [ __ ] oh
funny funny mush man
exam director be like yeah
no that's way more passionate there was
no [ __ ] passion there so [ __ ] off
this thing had passion it just wasn't
there I gotta try to finish Exxon now
I'm not gonna do that I'm gonna try man
I'm gonna try you said you're on episode
two I got to like episode two or three
yeah three is so [ __ ] bad oh my God
it's pretty because they never thought
anyone's going to get to three yeah
so that's like five minutes of episode
one I was ready to shut it off yeah it's
miserable they're just like they're so
lazy you just hit like other [ __ ]
stuff playing in the background when
they were recording the audio like
[ __ ] Rick and Morty
recording this [ __ ] oh my god well dude
thank you so much for coming on no thank
you very much a lot of fun hey look at
all these patrons look at all these
patrons flying by who's your favorite oh
yeah I'm a big fan of uh great Paul post
anything you want to shout out anything
you want to mention yeah
um no just thanks for having me on thank
you
thank you to inviting us to your complex
this is an amazing space and I think you
you defended your JoJo tank yeah did I
convince anyone do you guys think yeah
you convinced me that it is uh is it is
an understandable take okay I don't
agree yeah we'll allow it but I think
it's an acceptable yeah next time we'll
make more persuasive arguments here like
it'll be like a 30-minute essay yeah so
in the part one but no thank you so much
for coming on thank you guys yeah but
hey now you guys can stop asking when
we're gonna get Charlie on exactly but
yeah um obviously all of the links to
Charlie's stuff is in the description
below but uh hey thanks for watching
guys if you enjoyed this uh then go over
and support our patreon patreon.com
trash taste also follow us on Twitter
send us a memes on the subreddit if yeah
if you hate our face listen to us on
Spotify and uh yeah that's the end of
that thank you very much
foreign
[Music]